we've got tour dates to announce uh
Louisville uh Indianapolis
we added a show in Indianapolis
Shreveport
Louisiana Baton Rouge Louisiana uh
Corpus Christi uh Houston
uh we added a show in Houston added a
show in Phoenix added a show in New York
City and added a show in Austin Texas uh
those are all at theovan.com
t-o-u-r make sure to do ticketing
through those links to get accurately
priced ticketing and uh thank you guys
that's all Return of the Rat tour so if
you've already seen it it'll be similar
to that uh still just so you know we've
got lots of new merch up at
theovanstore.com check out the new
hitter hunting collection
also the new gang gang crew necks in
orange and purple and gold fits we got
the new Rat King t-shirt in purple and
black that thing that's the thing baby
if you haven't seen that one check it
out theovinstore.com
today's guest is a Grammy award-winning
musician and producer
um he creates he's one of the most
creative people I've ever met oh he's a
friend of mine
and um
and he's someone I really enjoy talking
to and having gotten to speak with him
in a while
so I'm grateful for our opportunity
today
he has produced music and written music
for and with some of the top artists in
the world uh I'm excited today to catch
up with him to learn a little bit more
about his creative process and to just
spend some time uh furthering our
friendship today's guest is the one and
only James Blake
[Music]
and tell you
[Music]
[Applause]
what are they called lazy boys the
things that
I saw one in friends at one point you
did
lazy boys are not a really big they're
not a thing in England bring your mic in
let's okay there we go with the seat you
mean
yeah like what they call a lazy boy
doesn't exist in in England I don't
think well I think because we got it
once they got to America people probably
got more lazy I would guess right and
they're like do you think that's what it
was it was okay so it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy I feel like a
little bit right it's a circular
situation
like I think the first chairs didn't
even have a seat on it it was just like
a straight up piece and then someone
lazy sat on it yeah and then they had to
create yeah they're like oh this could
be better right yeah right that's
interesting it's funny that we got to
America and created a lot of like lazy
stuff you know maybe I don't know
whether I don't know where the lazy
stereotype came from I mean
I mean
it seems like a pretty industrious Place
yeah especially around the time when
they got it well I think yeah because
then they hit the Industrial Revolution
you know I think a couple I don't know
when people even got here I mean there's
a lot of speculation but
um but you're from originally from
Britain I'm from England yeah you're
from England and so if somebody says
England is that
is that more top shelf than say in
Britain no no you know I'll be careful
how I say this uh no no uh there no it's
it's not I mean everywhere in Britain is
you know it's just a
sort of a collection of places when you
say Britain and I'm part of Britain as
well I'm part of the UK uh yeah I'm also
probably a mix of of a lot of different
things you know historically so
I think I'm a bit Irish a bit
um a bit Welsh oh the Welsh I hear about
sometimes yeah they travel it's down is
he well guaranteed do you think is he
who else that UFC guy
look that up Zach can you can you look
up if Darren till as well
I don't know you know what I've I've
really lost track of UFC recently I
don't know why yeah I haven't watched it
for a couple
he's English
can he be both
you could be both he could be both
somewhere I mean the Welsh is it I think
it's a dominant gene oh oh he's a
Liverpool man yeah I gotta I wish okay I
wish I had a better chart about the
British I don't have a good
you know I believe in it I've seen a lot
of the you know I believe I just I mean
I gotta see I wish I knew more
about the about the British yeah just
kind of what it feels like I feel like
you have better posture inside of your
soul that's what I think it feels like
when you talk when the British they have
like I think this this uh this myth that
we're sophisticated
it's very it's pervasive right but
I honestly don't know where it comes
from
and
I think I think it's just the way we
sound it's not real I you know what I
mean
I think sometimes phonetics and like
someone's accent can make them seem
something and then it's just all
can be complete bollocks I mean yeah
because the British they sound when
they're talking like there's perfectly
set silverware on the side of their
mouth that's what it feels like to me
yes when I hear someone british talking
like they even do that little spoon and
you're like what is that for you know
yeah when they say it's for shrimp
you're like how will you even use this
on a shrimp you know I'm not being a
pervert a little spoon yeah you know a
little spoon the little spin is for I
mean
for sugar in tea I guess I really don't
know I mean the spoon differences in in
size of teaspoons here it you know it it
catches me out a lot which is what I'm
making if you want to make anything but
yeah I think when I see British people I
guess there is like that yeah I feel
like I do feel a sophistication I feel
like I
I feel like I'm like they came out of
the library and they're giving me for I
feel like there's something about it to
an American person you know I just again
I don't know where it comes from because
I think when I came over here
I noticed that a lot of the smartest
people I'd met
were from every I mean I don't know you
know it's just you got smart people
everywhere dumb people everywhere and
you also were getting into an age where
you were probably gonna start meeting
more people you were in your field yes
so yes and also you know when it comes
to musicians
we're not
we don't tend to be the most
kind of um
articulate people for some reason
I think
we're not the best people to have
conversations with I find that with
musicians
um so I had to Branch out
not because I'm such a great
conversationalist but because I just
I noticed that a lot of my conversations
with musicians tended to be
more one-dimensional
and then outside of that there wasn't
like a broad and I myself didn't have
like a broad knowledge of stuff and and
because I think music sort of funnels
you into like a
you know it's a bit like
it's kind of like pavlovian conditioning
right if you if you get
uh if you're rewarded for for kind of
your
your primary way of speaking which is
through music probably if you're like a
writer or musician the likelihood is
that you're you're better at
articulating your emotions through music
and then
outside of that you can be kind of
stumped
um which is I think you find like a lot
of like very sort of socially anxious
musicians and stuff which I've
definitely been myself and then
yeah and then you then you're rewarded
for
for that one expression cons you know
constantly right of course maybe become
successful hopefully and then then
people pay you for that expression and
no one's paying you to talk yeah no
one's no one's paying you to express
yourself in any other way or be funny or
whatever it is right so yeah you can
have so much it's like yeah you start to
feel like that's where some of your
reward is is at and so that's where your
most your value is at and so then
yeah it makes sense to me yeah and then
I think after that you just start to
all the other muscles atrophy right so
so then chatting is not I mean when I
met my girlfriend I I wasn't
really finishing sentences
[Laughter]
because
I don't anyone's sort of required me to
yeah yeah they'd just be like oh we know
we know what he means he's probably that
was probably very funny wherever that
was going
um it's funny well this is great because
this is how you and I met I met your
girlfriend yeah and um she was a comedy
fan she loves comedy yeah she loves to
laugh and uh she introduced me to your
special oh she did yeah and uh we came
to see like the first one that's right
you guys came to see me um where do we
see you
um
Comedy Store
what's the what's it called yeah Comedy
Store Comedy Store here yeah well yeah
because I remember one time I saw her at
the comedy store and uh
she was like yeah I'm gonna catch a Uber
or something I was like I'll give you a
ride home you know she's like I don't
live far and I'm just thinking like I'm
like beautiful girl I got my hook time
you know I couldn't my hopes have been
lost I've been like like I'm like
literally while she's talking I'm like
oops get over here man I'm gonna pick
you up so I got my hopes up and uh I
drive her um you know I drive her it's
it's in Hollywood and it's kind of in
the Hills not not not it's it's in a
nice place there's a couple of right
yeah we've actually moved since then not
far yeah yeah yeah not way out there you
know yeah yeah but um and then I she's
like you have to meet my boy well that's
not a good improvisation for her but
she's like you've got to meet my
boyfriend yes and I was like oh God he
sounds like a great guy
um and she goes no he would absolutely
love you or she might have already said
that he's a fan of yours or yeah yeah
and then uh you guys came to the comedy
story yeah yeah one time I was very
nervous to meet you at the time yeah
yeah I was
well yeah because I think
you know there's this um
there's this Mutual like mutual
appreciation I think between Comedians
and musicians I think a lot of musicians
want to be Comedians and a lot of
comedians want to be musicians and you
know that's that's like a general rule
although I haven't ever heard you
express interest in being a musician uh
but I know nor do I want to be a
comedian but I think
I I think there's I didn't really have
any comedian friends at that point yeah
and we'd been watching a lot of stand-up
comedy and we've been going to the like
Comedy Store and we've been going to
like different shows and
I just kind of felt intimidated by the
idea that I needed to be funny
ah you know I thought like
not only did I did I really respect what
you did but I don't get I don't really
get Star Struck particularly yeah
because just through exposure to you
know the industry and stuff
but I also but in this one way I sort of
felt insecure I was like wait I think I
told you this before
um I was like I'm you know do I have to
like do I have to be on do I have to
like be funny and be smart and whatever
because your comedy was was smart and it
was funny and it was
I was like what's he and I didn't really
understand
the difference between the stage and the
off stage kind of person really well I
think it's interesting because yeah it's
funny when I've talked to you sometimes
I'm like dang do I need to know a lot
about music or can I just share about
music how I think and feel about it and
that yeah I don't know that much do I
have to pretend like I know all of the
names of every one of your songs like
right I think that happens a lot of
times when you meet somebody of a
certain thing right certain genre yes
you do you do that's so interesting yeah
yeah yeah
um so you know I'll be quizzing you on
that later if you know when you're ready
okay yeah there's a car I mean I do have
some I do have some favors man it's
funny you say that you're not that like
um would you say that words weren't very
per like I uh articulate yeah well I
don't I'm not saying I'm not in any way
articulate I'm just saying that as a
general rule right musicians like I had
to find my words really you know it was
a process like I I think you if you'd
met me maybe
sort of seven or eight years ago I
probably would have
well I probably wouldn't have sustained
a friendship for a start because I think
I would have been intimidated or not
been socially kind of comfortable enough
because especially not to do this I mean
there's no way how to come in here
this would have been way too much wow
yeah that's incredible man that's right
we've talked about a lot of this kind of
stuff this is where a lot of our
friendship kind of started was talking
about that sort of thing yeah yeah I
always admired how open you are about
you know mental health and like all this
other stuff and and your own kind of
shortcomings or your own kind of uh
things you don't know yeah you know
that's always been amazing to me and I
think that's probably
to me is like a huge strength of yours
is is is being the voice of people who
who are afraid to ask questions
because they're worried that they're
going to be you know made fun of or uh
in some way kind of mocked because
you know because there are a lot of
things
I mean it's hard to do sometimes talking
about the question especially when you
feel like the world is so fast and it
knows more than you yeah you know
especially these days if you feel like
you're sometimes from a certain area or
from a certain Financial class I would
be scared I remember when I was young to
ask questions in like a nice person's
house right like if it was a dump I was
like I'll just you know I know where you
are with that yeah dude I'm just out you
know I'm Alex trebeking in there but if
it was a nice place I'm like oh I should
be asking nothing yeah right now like
what does the little spoon do you know
stuff like that yeah but yeah it was
just it's interesting how like different
little Comfort worlds that people find
and and where you're okay to communicate
and uh yeah yeah it's scary
communication is kind of interesting I
mean it's
I mean obviously it's interesting that's
kind of a silly thing to say but no but
you do it really well and I think you
you managed to I mean I don't know how
you sit and talk like on your solo shows
oh it's miserable sometimes it must I
mean it must get hard sometimes because
I don't know how you
sustain that level of talking for that
long it's like an improvisation I I
sometimes
I mean I was thinking about it yesterday
thinking about things that we have in
common because I didn't because um
I I just
there's some like I know we have some
kind of like friend chemistry that I
sort of like but as but as on top of
that I think we have
a kind of there's some similarity
between the way you think and the way I
think when it comes to music and I think
sometimes when I when I wet when I see
the way you're reaching for words
it's like um
I find when I'm reaching for chords
sometimes
I have to find
a kind of abstract chord or like some
kind well
maybe in our new you know like a
an unusual chord or
whatever to to to nail the emotion I'm
looking for right and it's because the
standard ones won't won't do the
standard ones don't
current you know don't quite scratch the
itch of what I'm trying to think yeah
the roygbiv it doesn't have enough color
it's not though yes you want to you're
very specific yeah and it's like looking
for that very specific Hue and
you seem to do the same thing with words
it's like when
you're looking for like a word to
describe it I don't know it was like a
dog it's like a floor Bearer I can't
remember you just have this like you
know you want to get specific because
you want them to know exactly what you
feel yeah and it's like oh what you mean
yeah and so you know the the basic
language
doesn't always cut it it's interesting
man you know you have that what is it
lyric you have that lyric I could drink
a case of you and not follow oh well
that's a journey Metro lyrics which is
it oh it is there's an even better lyric
than I could ever write yeah no no it's
a cover but it's
it is the one of the best songs ever
written so I didn't know that yeah
that's so good man thanks man yeah yeah
yeah thank you thank you uh on behalf of
Jenny Mitchell yeah yeah
um what is something that I love uh oh
the
I gave you
punch lines oh yes man that's a good one
that one really really resonated with uh
I gave them punch lines they gave me
warning signs yeah
that reminds you so much of your music
to me matters I mean we'll get into your
music so much of like that is my song
yes it is
we were the way we uh oh uh say what you
will say what you will yeah yeah god
dude yeah thanks man appreciate it yeah
I gave you punch lines you gave me
warning signs that was like my whole
I felt like that was my whole childhood
man well I was like you know I would all
I had was like the way to make people
feel something was through laughter or
something it was so like
um
but everything felt like a warning it
was like the whole world felt like
everything felt like warning sounds like
any reaction people would give to me
I had to monitor every moment of it
because I was always scared when it
would go from
everything was okay to everything was
not okay yeah and man it was it's uh
yeah you have such a way it's like
watching
somebody well first of all you're like a
sound monkey like you like you're like
oh you're listening to your music and
you're like oh that's a sound okay I
didn't know that was a sound like you're
like I can almost see this like
chimpanzee like swinging out into the
unknown and then being like this is a
sound yeah yeah yeah it's um well you're
doing that with what you do that with
words it's funny and and maybe that's
some of what it is you know well I think
some of it in in like what you described
earlier like just then
um
the the
kind of
exploration it's like
when
you in order to emotionally regulate
yourself
you've kind of got to find
uh
words or comedic moments or
chords in my case to to just make it
feel better
and
that happens once and it feels a little
bit better and you're like okay
you subconsciously twig that that's now
gonna be your hmm you know and
but yeah so this is a place to go this
is a chord I can use this is a nice
landing spot yeah or a foothold it's
almost like you're doing some mountain
climbing like this is a a grip exactly
and it's not it's like like I I remember
like when I was a when I was a kid there
was this one standout I mean it's a
small moment but I remember it very
vividly which is where my friend was um
really
he's one of my best friends but you know
I didn't have many friends I have like
one friend at a time it was like you
know like a shop it was like one in one
out kind of thing
and
I just
had this day where he he just
relentlessly took the piss out of me
right and he was just being so cruel to
me because and I think that when I was
when somebody was my only friend I think
they they felt they knew they could do
that right
so
just you know when I was much younger
like
eight or nine or something anyway so
this kid is is uh I'm just like oh I'm
just feeling terrible
and I go into the other room
and I start playing piano
just I just get up and I just go and
start playing piano
he comes in and uh
and just mocks me even harder for coming
over to play the piano to like to like
oh is this your sad song that you're
writing because
and I remember thinking at the time yeah
it is the sad song I'm writing because
you're taking the piss out of me it is
the sad song
and
that just that just is and always was
my uh my way of uh you know it's like if
I became like a pressure cooker yeah
emotionally then the only thing I had
the only Outlet music was music it was
the only way I could get it out or if
you were like even like a rice cooker
like that was your rice that was my rice
yeah yeah that's cool man yes I learned
to make you know like a like a sous chef
like a Japanese sous chef I learned to
make the rice so many times
um you know day in day out that
eventually I became a a um
a restaurateur yeah like a I was going
to say Michelin star but that would be
that would that would be high you know
highly self-aggrandizing I think that's
easy to say man I think a master of of
music I got good at Rice
simply I want to let you know if your
New Year's goals are to manage your
budget better
and to save money
then you need rocket money it's that
simple
that's right you can say goodbye to last
year's outdated disorganized methods of
managing your money and say hello to
Rocket money
the best way to hack your finances in
2023 over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about that's
right you have maybe Netflix or uh
butcher Bobby and you every month some
dude's sending you a filet of something
deer meat veal uh
human damn I might be saying your name
you know any you know you don't know
[ __ ] you're eating it
you know maybe you're eating a steak and
it had a damn set of keys in it like
damn all right
but this company
helps you keep tabs on what you're
paying for
because a lot of these subscription
Services make it too hard to cancel
rocket money will quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you can stop paying for the ones you
don't want
rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as a click of a
button simply find the subscription you
don't want and press cancel and Rocket
money will cancel it for you no more
long hold times with customer service or
tedious emailing back and forth over
three million people have used rocket
money saving the average person up to
720 a year
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com Theo
that's
rocketmoney.com Theo rocketmoney.com
Theo Bluetooth baby get em
get em baby
get them wiener lifters baby
you know what I'm saying put that
stilled in your meat son
up that wiener dog you know what I'm
saying Bluetooth
you don't like swallowing pills no
problem
Bluetooth sealed an apple and title
Apple tablets are chewable you can chew
them
Bluetooth is an online prescription
service
so there's no doctor's visits no awkward
conversations hey buddy my wiener you
don't even have to do it
no waiting in line at the pharmacy ships
right to your door I've got them I dig
them
Bluetooth tablets are made in the U.S
hey
that's it here's a special deal for you
guys try Bluetooth free when you use our
promo code t-h-e-o at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com promo code Theo to
receive your first month for free
well I think I'll like you know I'm kind
of a I don't want to say your music is
for like emotional people right because
I don't want to judge your music you
know I'm a kind of an emo kind of guy
like in a lot of ways I sometimes yeah
you're here's your songs it's almost
like
I feel like the length of your song is
like the length that takes a tear to go
from like an eye to a cheek sometimes in
a strange like some songs some of them
are more valid you know
um some I feel like it's like somebody
like hitchhiking just through like a
bunch of emotions kind of
um yeah they're all they're very
they're like highly emotional things
also yeah that's why it seems so
specific to me which you do it's like
God this seems like it's not like
somebody laid some cement it's like each
thing here is like a somebody put a step
here right and this one is a certain
depth from the soil and it's a certain
softness to it of the stone or whatever
it is it seems very intentional yes yeah
actually I think there's there's two
there's good and bad that can come from
being so intentional and being perceived
to be so intentional right so
sometimes it's not intentional
and it just seems like it is because I'm
improvising and and I was just feeling a
certain way and it just came out like
that and then I just edited it and just
like put it in the song right and so in
moments like that
I think
when the perception becomes okay you're
super intentional and you're and you're
always in control
ultimately it leads to a place where you
have to keep up a a keep up that image
but but B people don't question you
you know people will just like
assume that you know what you're doing
and when you're working with people
they're just like oh I'm sure he knows
what he's doing I'm sure that's fine I'm
sure that's good and they just Gaslight
themselves
because it might just be [ __ ] it might
just be not a good melody or not a good
lyric or whatever oh so it can almost
corner you in a way yeah definitely
oh that's interesting yeah people don't
tend to and it's Brave you to notice
that and just say that like yeah
sometimes my own ability or how people
perceive some of my ability yeah and
then Corner me into a place where I'm
not getting probably Earnest feedback
yeah on if something is quality enough
for the situation or not yeah and also
people because they're not as advanced
at exactly the thing you do they might
be as advanced as something else right
but because they're not as advanced as
exactly the thing you do and the exact
way that you came up
build you know doing that up the
mountain
um
you
you're not speaking the same like you
know that they don't they don't feel
that they have the knowledge to confront
you on the idea that's not good
sometimes ah I could see that too
especially well that's one thing I was
going to say about when I met you since
you're taller and British or sound
British anyway I'm thinking oh man you
seem older
then you are and not saying you're not a
per a great age but when I first met you
I'm I'm 34. just are you really just
turned 34 yeah well congratulations
thank you very much but I thought that
you were a lot it just it gives you a
wiseness I think to people that maybe
you don't even know I think so that
probably adds into the same thing where
it's like oh man this guy's a dang
wizard you know
do you think there's um for an American
person anyway I'd be like yeah no I I
don't know I I think I think people have
a you know do you believe in old souls
and young souls and yeah stuff like that
I don't know how much I mean it's
obviously not something I could prove
but I think these these kind of um
phrases mean something hmm
uh right I don't know if they always
mean exactly what you know the literal
sense of like you know someone having
been here many times or whatever but
whatever people trying to say when they
say that right
I do identify with that I've always felt
like a little haunted it doesn't yeah it
doesn't mean that I'm it doesn't mean
that I'm like
in any way a wizard or in any way like
no because I think actually if anything
I'm in theory I I feel kind of uh
insufficient in a lot of ways it's it's
your desk clerk at that point you're
running you're running a hotel for souls
for Souls yeah right you know like
you're you're at a certain point yeah
sorry to step on you there no no no but
I think that's kind of what if like if
it feels like some people it feels like
it's their first time through the Galaxy
you know you meet him it's like oh this
is a baby Soul it feels like and it's
not even judging that heaven if you feel
like you or resonate with being an old
soul that it makes you better or
anything no it doesn't it just makes you
you're a damn you know you can be more
cynical you can be more sort of jaded
you can be yeah you can feel kind of um
too much you can feel too much you can
yeah easily overwhelmed you can feel
maybe I mean and these these obviously
these character traits don't aren't just
applied to the old soul but they can be
applied to any like a couple of
different character or
personality types and and like there's
also all sorts of psychological analyzes
and assessments that you could put on
this but
uh I think
I feel sometimes I mean my job
extends Beyond Purdue I mean I'm a
producer but I feel a lot of the time
like a therapist and and like a
therapist a lot of therapists are very
[ __ ] up
they're not they're not people who you
should necessarily take
um you know all of your uh life lessons
from it that or or indeed they might not
be practicing exactly
what they preach but you know they're
also people who've who've uh who've got
an overwhelming sense of
uh empathy and probably quite easy to
overwhelm themselves and and they've
learned to like learn to vocalize what
it is that they're feeling so that other
people can can vocalize what they're
feeling
yeah you know I think I realized and
obviously I haven't gone to school to be
a therapist no I'm nothing like a
therapist in any way I don't know man I
think that but your music might be right
right and that's okay and that's that's
what's interesting sometimes about
having any sort of gift in the world I
believe everybody has some gift it could
be some people's smile might be their
song it's like man they just smile at
you and it is like it can lift you up
just as much as hearing like you know
um some Michael McDonald or something
you know or some uh trying to think of
something good yeah or Nelly or
something but um
how do you draw the line between Michael
McDonald and Nelly how did that I was
just trying to get some diversity yeah
trying to get that I think I was trying
to get diversity right and now
therapeutic guys or Nelly was the last
time I think that a lot of white people
felt like they could really dance
honestly that's interesting when he came
out with Country Grammar and this is
almost a little bit before your time but
when he came I remember it yeah God I
remember feeling like
remember thinking this is an amazing
song and I still can't dance yeah
I mean it was we it was just our last
hurray I feel like with the legs you
know it was the last Caucasian hurray
anything so when things were still
moving below the hips yeah right yeah
um so how how did you so in terms of
like your
because I want to know more about
the connection between your emotional
your upbringing and comedy and why
why you sort of went into it like what
what were their moments where
you got a laugh
from saying something in it in a certain
way and and it helped the situation it
helped like your relationship with
someone or it stopped a situation from
going but badly or whatever it became
like almost like a you know
um
diplomatic kind of tool or whatever
I think um
you know I think
I didn't have a lot of feelings as a kid
I didn't have a lot of like comfortable
feelings probably you know there wasn't
a lot of comfort in our home and there
was a lot of question marks and not a
lot of information
right so there wasn't a lot of
information
um there was a lot of
attention to uh learning you know my mom
made sure that we were learning
um like
um reading and yeah reading doing our
homework you know uh
but always reading and my mother was an
English major
um that's interesting so she you know
knew words and she would use big words
and she would use words that they would
try to kick out of our town you know I
remember they would come with torches
when she'd use certain words they'd
never seen it you know they'd be like
she's a witch
and my dad would be like I wish she was
you know and so it was like you know my
mom really probably had one of the best
vocabularies in our town right um but I
didn't have much affection for my mother
and that's okay she didn't have a lot to
give and um so I think I probably
somewhere in my head thought that well
if I have War if I'm using words maybe
she'll see me you know or if I'm well if
and when once I started to make people
laugh I'm like oh man they
you can make somebody
I just never knew if I was if I was okay
to my mother I never knew if I was
approved of by her so once she withheld
the approval yeah and I don't even know
if she knew she was she didn't know she
was doing no people sometimes don't yeah
she just had like this kind of emotional
kind of autism where she didn't
understand that that was necessary
and so I think once I saw somebody laugh
it was like oh
it was like I'm okay for a minute got it
you know and so then I think that just
became an addiction that was beyond
I didn't have a choice at that point but
yeah you're just compelled to do it it
was yeah because I you have to I think
feel okay at certain points as a human
absolutely yeah and also all of it is a
survival thing I mean it's like anything
that you had to do
even the things that you're ashamed of
um yeah ultimately have to be chalked up
to
something that got you by something that
kind of helped you survive
um yeah I'm grateful that our Arts at
least aren't like looked down upon very
much by Society because a lot of people
they end up into
the dark arts or things that are you
know more taboo and it's just their
survival methods you know I mean I look
at like strippers and you know some sex
workers and stuff like that sometimes
like oh they're just trying to you know
Express themselves or something oh yeah
I mean I I also it's just
it's just a job isn't it and I guess I
guess the
I'm not overly educated on the
complexities of of sex work but I I'd
say
I would do a little I probably would
yeah
yeah ultimately it's if it came down to
it to feed your family go do what you
gotta do
um I mean I I felt like I was compelled
to do music did you well it sounds like
it even from that story of like you know
you're like I'm gonna go in the other
room here my buddy's being a real prick
and I'm gonna express myself yeah yeah
so yeah I think it's just interesting
how our expression comes out like yeah I
mean it was maybe it was the
I want I wonder if it's written it's
kind of written
the writings on the wall from the moment
you kind of oh that is it Destiny or is
it like well it's like I don't really
believe in people being naturally
talented particularly I don't really
believe in kind of genetic I mean maybe
predisposition
um or like something inherited kind of
Consciousness but I don't really believe
in people being like born with a gift
and [ __ ] like that so do you believe
that music like so you were very
inclined especially I don't know all the
instruments you play James I've got to
Pat this down because it so easily looks
like I've got an erection when in this
thing it kind of like
I'm having a good time
[Laughter]
sell some tickets bro raise that man
I could do a Revival in there man it's
good
um is piano like your main instrument is
that okay to say or no
uh yeah you play other instruments no no
it is my management yeah right because
when I see you on stage you're at the
keyboard of the piano yeah yeah okay
yeah
um yeah do you feel like
that yeah that art say art is just like
an energy and it's gonna come out of
people
it's gonna find its way out into the
world because it's just the way the
whole world is kind of put together that
the energy has to come out and so
it finds its way through you so you can
harness it or adjust to it but that it's
or you can choose to use it or not maybe
if you never even get to the Keys and it
just kind of hits a cul-de-sac inside of
you
yeah yeah is that kind of more what you
feel like it's just that's a nice way of
putting it I think um
I sometimes feel sorry for
musicians and and artists and stuff
rather than kind of uh
mythologize them or kind of
um
put them on a pedestal because
in order for you to have arrived at that
point where you need music as your your
expression
something had to happen you know and
something had to make you boil over so
much that there was only one way that
was going to be you know and it just
happened to be this
um
but it's not necessarily the most
comfortable life not to say it's the
worst life I mean I've I'm I feel super
privileged to do what I do and
I'm uh
I'm very lucky
um but I'm also one of the lucky ones
you know there's
hun millions of musicians who are not
rewarded in in the same way for
for basically expressing a lot of pain
and
it's
not an efficient method of doing it
either like I don't really feel that
much better after I make a song
if I'm depressed I'm just depressed if
I'm anxious I'm just anxious if I'm
sad I'm just sad
you know making a song isn't going to
fix that and I had to find other ways
eventually but it felt like if we were
to use the extend the pressure pressure
cooker analogy it's like
through ART
I was basically just like laying a
little steam out every now and again but
I was never just like turning it off you
know it's like
I wanted to turn it off
I wanted to stop the endless
swell of pain and anxiety and depression
and stem the flow and and I had to find
other ways to do that and once I did
that I was able to look at music a bit
more objectively and it didn't have to
it didn't have to prove everything it
didn't have to be everything all at once
there was less pressure on the songs I I
didn't have to like be the biggest
artist I didn't have to like prove
myself to the people the kids at school
I didn't have to prove myself to even
myself you know that or less anyway I
mean there's always going to be a bit of
all of those things yeah um but there's
less pressure on the art
well it's fascinating yeah because when
you identify with it so much which is
what happens sometimes as you get
successful it's like this is it this is
all you not this is all you are but
there's
you've become so like in tandem with it
that everything you do every if you put
out one wrong thing yeah you become so
close to your thing like
it's not just fluid anymore yeah it
feels like uh they're attached on you
like sloths kind of and you can't get
them off or you're afraid to let them
just kind of just leave them on the path
of the forest you know
um
yeah it's interesting because some of
your music I I feel like I'm like Eeyore
like Eeyore that showed up at a rave
kind of you know
uh
which is kind of perfect for me I can
totally see why like that's that is who
I am I like okay good thank you for for
noticing me
thank you for letting me judge you man
because I'm not winning the pig
yeah and I'm not Christopher Robin
no even though but that's the that's the
reason you might be I think you might be
Christopher I don't know maybe I gotta
look at some of this you might be
winning the Poo actually
I think I'm crossed up I think they had
a child yeah it could have been I mean
who knows they could have been they
walked off into the sunset and after
that we don't really know we're missing
a few chapters yeah yeah AAA Milne let
us down
um what was it so was there a kind of a
moment because you and I have talked
about this it's I forget some of the
things you and I have talked about
because you and I our friendship has
just kind of had a Hiatus through the
pandemic right yeah yeah and um because
I stayed in California already where I
wasn't allowed out my house yeah you
moved to was it Nashville Tennessee yeah
where people are just yeah we're out of
here yeah people are sneezing down each
other's orifices you know yeah just
testing the theory yeah you know yeah
yeah everybody has hep C now but nobody
else yeah they got everything else
um but yeah was it because I remember
there was I think I remember there was a
time where you kind of were
like do you and I talked about different
modalities for relieving like
um whether it be depression or
whatever's going on in our lives yeah
yeah did you have a time where you kind
of came to a head with some of that sort
of stuff I did during the pandemic oh
yeah you tried to get me on the EMDR yes
I did I uh I was evangelizing EMDR and I
even went I even went a few times yeah
and I see a woman now with EMD that's
amazing yeah yeah and I mean I remember
you saying it helped and and but
initially the thing was with the MDR is
that you you don't really
and you don't go and then afterwards you
like
necessarily feel what's happened it has
this very strange slightly sci-fi effect
on you where you don't even remember
feeling the way you felt when you went
in
um
tiny bit Men in Black
uh so a lot of people kind of come out
of it and going you know
oh yeah I don't really think anything
happened but then they stopped the
pattern they've been in yeah and they
don't even realize and they're just like
oh I didn't um you know I didn't
endlessly turn on and off the the hob
and like check to see if it was still on
or whatever the OCD thing is or like
they didn't they don't that pattern just
isn't manifesting anymore because the
trauma that leads to it has been
disconnected uh from feeling it yeah it
is kind of Black Mirror huh it's a kind
of go behind the scenes and adjust a
cable or something and then the next
time like your Christmas tree lights
blink they don't blink in that weird way
that was uncomfortable or something yeah
exactly yeah there's behind the bookcase
in yeah Interstellar yeah it's kind of
behind the bookcase yeah
um the are there other modalities and
stuff that you've tried
um I did mushrooms yeah which was quite
very helpful for me actually I mean I I
go into a really bad depression when I
take mushrooms because
um I think I'm allergic to them or
something and it just yeah just kind of
I go get really depressed for a couple
days
um afterwards or not during afterwards
yeah no during is amazing I love I love
them but I've only done them a few times
but every time I've done them
something's changed in my life like
majorly changed
um I've either given up an addiction
or I've
you know for example I I came off
Twitter uh or stopped kind of really
using it
um because
I'm kind of checking it all the time and
like being quite engaged in it and
invested in in kind of what how I was
doing you know how other people's
opinions and and even other people's
opinions of what I was saying and you
know
very overwhelming place for an artist to
someone who's easily overwhelmed but
also I think it's an overwhelming place
for a lot of people
um and maybe they're not admitting it uh
but uh and stressful yeah um it feels
stressful even hearing you say it yeah
and and um
and it was kind of at a point where a
lot of conversations were reaching a
kind of fever pitch
um politically and
I just felt trepidatious about even
being involved because I felt like all
of my real life conversations were
really compassionate and empathetic and
loving
even if we didn't agree on something
you know like ours like we don't always
agree on everything but we we just
you know we approach each conversation
we love and respect so you know but on
Twitter it was like the opposite of that
it felt like if you didn't have the
right opinion for the for the group you
know you you were
you you're sort of out of the group or
whatever whichever group that is right
and I just
felt really over time really really
stressed about that Dynamic and and um
took mushrooms one day uh we were sort
of on a like a road trip
and uh we were sitting by a pool
and
I think this was the first time I
actually ever did them
was during the pandemic
um
and
I remember saying to my friend I'm not
really sure these are doing anything
um yeah totally sneaky right
and then he goes well you you've been
taking a photo you've been taking
photographs of that same flower for the
last two hours
and I noticed and I look down at my
phone and there was like 400 I was like
scrolling through this 400 photographs
of this flower is really beautiful
flower but
um in hindsight probably
the mushrooms had something to do with
that
so um I so I just
looked down at my phone open Twitter and
it just looked like a Vortex oh yeah
there was a very very strange
like it was like fragmenting at the
edges you know like like an actual
Vortex
um and it looked like
extremely Dark Energy it's hard to
describe it
um
in sober wording but it was
you know at the time I would would have
just kind of felt this horrible
um kind of anxiety looking at it
and I just there and then deleted the
app
and just put the phone down and just got
on with my day and I didn't reinstall it
um
and there were a couple of other things
I did as well I did it with Instagram I
did it with like field because I just
noticed that the phone and actually the
phone itself was like just looked like
it was like charged with horrible like
nebulous like dark energy like felt like
a black hole basically yeah and it felt
like it was like drawing me towards it
but not in a good way like in a way that
um made me feel like I was dying so I
just thought no I'm that's telling me
something this is right you know I also
noticed the way my dog reacts to my
phone
he
very often pours it away but also just
just won't engage with it he'll only
engage with me and if I'm engaging with
it then he'll he'll just kind of
walk off wow so it's almost like here's
a piece of life
telling you hey man that's not life yes
yeah that's what's very well put that's
what's something about mushrooms man
you'll give you a little clue like I did
this Ayahuasca treatment and I came home
right and I cut on like Dateline or some
like murder show or something oh wow and
yeah it's probably is that is that
advised was that did your Shaman tell
you to do that
I would say unadvised right so I'd say I
was working you know I was going off
script
um do you have another water Tunes act
do you mind please brother
um no thank you so I was going off
script but I turned it on and it was
everything in me was like don't you see
how bad this is someone died and you're
sitting here watching it as like a wow
and it wasn't it was it wasn't a
dateline episode it was like a um some
murder like invest yeah yeah but
something that was like really dark so
it kind of uh exposes the
thank you mate yeah yeah exposure
sometimes like it's just a level of
truth that I think the addictiveness of
modern day society that we're not able
to feel anymore and it almost feels like
something that you would have felt like
a long time ago in like your ancestral
like right if you if you lived in a in a
more sort of primitive like back in the
day like more you know no technology no
and
and it's it's as if somebody handed to
you then yeah
and goes and goes
um
you know when you wake up you're going
to check this
and you're going to scroll through
all the things that are happening way
outside of your group
um you're gonna
you're gonna check for the opinions of
others
and they're going to tell you how you're
going to feel today and you're going to
watch a bunch of videos and you're going
to watch watch a bunch of people have
sex
and you're gonna watch and you're gonna
like
play games on here and they're not here
they're not in front of you with all
these other people they're not
interactions with real people you're
going to play games on this thing
um and most of your interaction it you
know you're you're gonna you're gonna
look at this for at least 12 hours a day
and when you set this down you're gonna
feel like there's nothing of you when
you set it down you're going to be
unsatisfied with what the the world is
like oh because this thing is going to
stimulate you so much
if somebody told you that when you had
no technology and you'd never seen
anything like that before you would tell
them to [ __ ] off
immediately yeah get away from me with
that [ __ ] dark magic I don't want to
ever see you again
this show and episode is sponsored by
betterhelp
we are grateful for them
better help if you've had uh you know if
you've had problems like I've had
organizing your brain keeping your
thoughts on track
getting into the mechanics of your brain
sometimes you can't get under your own
hood that's the tough part you don't
know the right questions to ask yourself
and you can't do it alone that's a thing
you can't do it alone
better help can help
working with a therapist
they will help you get closer to the
best version of you
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and it's
entirely online
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge that's right
if you're feeling overwhelmed if you're
feeling you're just not showing up to
life in the way that you want to
better help can't help they've helped me
if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
Theo today to get 10 off your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash t-h-e-o betterhelp.com
Theo I love how even your meanness is
pretty kind I don't want to ever see
yeah I can you kill them you might kill
them yeah you might kill them you might
kill them and throw this thing away so
that no other human ever had to
experience this yeah and
just I mean it goes on you know all your
friends all your friendships are going
to be kind of regulated through this
thing well we don't have a voice anymore
it's like the talent if you get up and
just stand up on a soapbox now and speak
you look like inside you're looking like
insane right if you if you were to yes
that's the crazy part too so it's like
we're all there's no if I go up and just
said like one of the more mundane tweets
that I've ever sent you know uh hoping
that a lot of people would be like yeah
me too yeah like yeah and then it would
just like spin into virality
and you just set it in the street on a
on a soapbox or you just got up and said
it people be like
you're right yeah go home this guy's not
doing good yeah he's he's saying
he's saying strange relatable mundane
things
but I'm on my way to work and I need to
go and get a coffee you know it's not
somebody like you queer we can take that
out
but somebody would yell something like
that I'd be like maybe but you know
but also but also porridge can be made
with milk and also water
yeah don't you know spread the news yeah
it's amazing with oat milk
um
you know you've you're some of your
journey with music as an outsider you
know I didn't know even much about your
genre music until I met you and I
remember
my girlfriend at the time Megan I think
it was we came to see you perform at a
church over in
in the Presbyterian church or was it um
in downtown was that that wasn't the
will tournament it might be the
Presbyterian Church
he was like a cool night time was it
actually a church I think it was
yeah then it was Presbyterian I think
because it was like some special show
you were doing or something it was
really amazing
um when I got into more music I listened
like in the beginning you had a lot of
or I don't know the total beginning but
early on some of the stuff you released
like these EPS that had like it was just
a lot of Beats and sounds and yeah you
know kind of wanderings and less like
lead vocals more more kind of abstract
like collages of [ __ ] yeah yeah was it
scary to then put your voice out there
did you always know you were going to
because your voice is like a big thing
especially for someone who comes from a
place of like you know uncertainty or
shyness or you know some of the Realms
that we've talked about like emotionally
like was that scary to put your voice
out
or did it seem like just the next
instrument it was I mean there was a lot
of there was a lot of toxic masculinity
floating around especially that time but
like
I remember when the first like one of my
earliest memories
was
um
I was upstairs in my parents house
and I was like 12 or 13 or something and
I was playing what I used to do one of
the ways I learned to trade I'd train my
ear which I didn't realize I was doing
but I just enjoyed doing it
was I'd play to records so I'd put a CD
on
and I sit at my like
keyboard like you know cheap just piano
keyboard thing like electronic kind of
thing think uh Ross from friends you
know doing the thing uh pressing the
little drum thing and just playing yeah
and then playing to the CD
and learning all the like vocal runs and
like learning how to play the chords and
like Stevie Wonder and like Mariah Carey
and all these people
and I was playing at the time I was
playing with the Whitney Houston song
uh I can't remember the name of the song
very famous song I Will Always Love You
that no no it was it was
I believe the children of the future
[Music]
yeah you still remember that it looks
amazing yeah so that one
I loved that song and I was playing it
and the chords are amazing they're like
very you know they're a tiny bit cheesy
it's a bit of a Cheesy song but it's
like one of the best ever slightly
cheesy songs pop songs and so anyway I'm
and
I'm singing at the top of my lungs and
the windows open
and my I've got a couple of friends who
live four doors down right I'm playing
very loud I didn't realize the window
was open opening the windows it's your
first song on the radio basically
basically yeah and it's it's me
it's me broadcasting this yes extremely
kind of I'd say at that point you know
being a being a young man uh very Billy
Elliott type moment very very yeah like
very like I'd say
in terms of our understanding of
masculinity at the time not the most
masculine thing I could be doing right
right and
I remember at the time one of them
shouting some homophobic slur from Three
Doors Down
and and just being like you sound like
probably where you know and and it
really like crushed me at the time
because
I didn't see music through a lens of
like sexuality or
I didn't see the problem in being gay or
being bi or being anything like it I
just was like but I did understand that
there was a social
kind of rejection of being gay and
social you know all that
and
I just kind of
froze and like so I started to associate
music and singing with something
shameful and feminine and like all these
things that like were not
not accepted it went from like 100 meter
dash to like just like hurdles now again
you're like now these these different
things I have to make sure that they
check enough of these things yeah like
don't be too like don't be too don't
express yourself too much because then
you're this and don't and so you know I
sort of kept and it wasn't just that but
there was a multiple reasons why
and they really showed anyone that I
sang I would go to the practice rooms uh
at school
every day and I was you know very often
like extremely sad and depressed and
kind of going in there and just playing
and [ __ ] crying and like being you
know so British very British is that
British extreme well no the British
thing to do is to is to um
is to not find an outlet at all and then
just abuse somebody
yeah yeah
physically or emotionally or or indeed
you know in any other way just just find
someone to to kind of
um or not even just someone but everyone
yeah just like make other people
uh experience the pain that you're
supposed to process wow so uh I actually
found a way I found an outlet
so I didn't have to like be a [ __ ] to
everyone else basically and I um
found myself
just keeping it a secret
um
that you had this Talent yeah like or
that you were excited to sing yeah that
I could sing and and that I could sing
you know by that point I was a good
singer I was by the time I've been
singing since I was
two yeah I mean you had some notes where
I'm checking my watch I'm like is this
note gonna end
my gosh it's like waiting for a long
train to pass I feel like there's one of
those Americans
Jesus come God this guy's just the
Amtrak this guy's riding this the B-flat
to north
um yeah so so that's you know like I
ended up to cut a long story short uh
eventually I started a little bit
singing in like school like assemblies
and [ __ ] but I generally just kept it
quiet and then when I was making music I
I think I carried over that
that uh shame and I just you know the
dance music scene was super male
dominated
um and a lot of the
discussion around it is like it's very
uh it was very toxically masculine at
the time
and so
when I started to sing there were a lot
of comments a bit similar to what the
guy had shouted at me yeah Three Doors
Down you know like just very like and
but they did they couldn't say like
because you know things had moved on and
and they were adults and they were they
didn't want to like expose themselves of
being homophobic or or whatever but they
were saying stuff that kind of like
they're almost dog whistling like you do
you can't do this because that's this
right right right and and kind of just
discouraging me from expressing myself
basically it's such a weird pattern of
comfort there there's almost a comfort
in people even doing that yeah it's like
this old thing it's like you know I
would always Envision like there's a
there's some black as kids on a white
guy's lawn and the black guy comes out
and yells the inward but then he goes
inside and he's learning the moonwalk
you know it's like what's the analogy
there I'm trying to trying to put it
together
um
don't you understand what you mean I
think it's that somebody will just say
something that they like has been like
part of a pattern okay but then they
don't even realize they're going inside
and now they're trying to learn like a
black guy's day they've been practicing
so the white guy saying then what or the
black guy the white guy or the white
guys oh I see sorry so they've their
their culture they're racially kind of
um living a double existence and say
yeah you don't even realize it it's like
because then they're not they're like
they have like hey they're saying
hateful things but ultimately they they
still but they're also learning part of
this culture they're learning like a
music or a dance or something at the
same time yeah they're they're confused
basically yeah just like some things are
just patterns they're not the best
patterns and you know obviously but some
even hateful things people say are just
like they don't know what else to say
they're ingrained also they can be so
deeply ingrained in people as a kind of
like uh form of expression that they're
not even aware of what the words
what they mean yeah they they lose
there's a thing called semantic
Association where you
where in the moment you can say a word
so many times that it loses its meaning
completely and you know like
access if you said that like 400 times
or even probably 10 times in a row you
start it just starts to be a word that
has no power whatsoever or any
connotation it just becomes like a
shape of sound we hear that even with
music you hear a song so many times it's
like ah I'm gonna listen to this my
whole road trip and then yeah
at the 30th time you're done you know
yes
um so is there another Evolution you
start to feel like for your music and
not that you need one or anything but
yeah I think we always need one
yeah yeah yeah I've always wanted but
even by putting your voice in right so
one point it was like okay I'm gonna put
my voice in like yeah something new and
different for me kind of or or put my
voice out there to people attached to my
music
um do you feel like there's just I'm
just trying to think like what would
something else even look like I guess
like a band or oh yeah well you know I
kind of have a band we've played with
live but I there is um
there's always a
slight
insecurity in me that like I'm not shift
I'm not changing up enough the neck
every phase that we go into like whether
it's a new album or something like that
but
I've tended to find that the
the three-piece band that I play with
is just the best for for me and it's
always kind of been that way uh and
but singing
is like
it's a form of expression unlike
anything I've ever had yeah and I guess
I just I I just love doing it and it
really like it feels great and it's
it's
just always it's always challenging and
it's like even just staying on the Note
like I I have this voice where
you I can kind of easily fall off the
note and it almost sounds like I'm about
to fall off the note but I but hopefully
I don't sometimes I just do
um but I don't have the most pure
clear voice you know someone like
Whitney Houston for example is just like
you know super defined
notes
a lot of mine are quite
um
precarious I think um yeah it's a
perfect example kind of a view it's I
don't know man it's really interesting
to know you and hear your music
um
same with your comedy it's interesting
to see it's kind of fascinating because
it one thing I always
sort of um found fascinating was just
how
you've internalized your childhood and
like the way people like all of your
memories of of all the stories you have
of like where you grew up
are so
Vivid
I can't remember most of the people in
my town
I mean
I remember some of them but I feel like
we grew up in
pretty different places and and
a lot of the things that you remember
and pick up on of the people that you
grew up around
maybe it's the way you're telling them
but
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened
near you oh yeah a lot of pervs I think
we grew up around there a lot of people
perv and out well I think when people
don't have much they play with their
body you know or they're like you know
you get reduced to kind of real limbic
type of behaviors you know sexual or
perved out or you know and especially
you get out there in a rural areas where
people aren't as educated there's a lot
more kind of
you know I don't want to say incest but
people touching each other a little
early yeah you know in that sort of
behavior I grew up in you know the kind
of the countryside uh or not it's not
the countryside the horse or anything
didn't have a horse okay
um that's where I draw the line I did
meet a couple yeah
um but I didn't ever ride one and um I
just
I just I'd like
there were characters Where where I was
from definitely
um but I think I don't I guess I don't
draw on them as inspiration yeah because
they probably I probably avoided most
people I think ah whereas I think you
must have just been more like viscerally
attached yeah we were more loose I'll
just seeing stuff you know yeah it's not
much like supervision or like yeah and I
didn't want to be at home my father was
so old my mother was gone there was like
a clean there was like a um babysitter
around so it was just so like I don't
know it's just just being out and about
you know and then your imagination
becomes so big because you something
needs to have some value to you so your
imagination creates like a lot like I
think it pays attention to a lot of
stuff yeah and it uh attached it sorry
it wants you to have a bigger world so
your maybe your imagination gets
attached to something else inside of you
and they kind of grow synonymously maybe
yeah because do you feel like when you
go into rooms with people in like
Hollywood or or even just anywhere you
are
do you feel like your imagination is
sort of overgrown in a way that theirs
hasn't do you sometimes feel like uh
like you've still got
the Curiosity of about people and about
like
things that a lot of people seem to have
like you have quite a um
quite a
like zest for that kind of thing that
like a lot of people don't seem to don't
seem to have like an OBS you know you're
Keen to like observe the the thing that
a lot of people wouldn't have noticed
which you know is it I mean
that in itself is like a is like a a
love of life it's not even though like I
know that you've gone through a lot and
you've and you've talked about you know
bouts of depression and that's and kind
of not being interested and stuff but
it's like even at your least interested
even at your least engaged with humanity
and everything you still seem so curious
well thanks man I think um
well some of it is I think you have to
you start to develop a sense I need to
know what is very important to this
person that's in front of me right now
because if I need them right or if I
need to let them know I need
communication from them or I need them
to see me I need to be able to get to
them immediately yeah so maybe there's a
part in you that's like oh you can tell
this about him or you can tell this or
you could you know see by the way that
they turn their neck or fix their hair
or put something in their pocket that
you can Envision this bigger World
behind them that you can either make a
way for it to be funny to them or it can
be really acute to them and it can be
very factual maybe sometimes I think
it's develop I think you just developed
this sense in case I need someone yeah
um I need everything I can get to show
this person that I may that I can attach
to them like a like a like a um like a
detective
yeah I think it is I think a part of you
kind of become some type of a detective
you know because it's like you're
noticing stuff on people you know it's
like when the in detective shows where
they're like yeah well you know his his
right but his right shoe had a lace
untied yeah which means that recently he
was well it's like he's the kind of
person who he's he's not no he's he
doesn't have OCD he's not he's you know
he's not paying attention he's he's
loose he can he can't be trusted but you
know it's like they'll draw all these
conclusions from just that one
aspect of someone's uh appearance or
something but you would also do it on
the other side you would know what could
hurt that person right you know right
and you could never used that and then
regretted it oh yeah I think growing up
especially as a defense mechanism you
would use it yeah around our house like
with communicating with my brothers and
sisters it was the only way we
communicated was uh very
rudely uh making fun there was no like
affection nobody like taught us you got
to be brothers and said there was no
so you just find the thing that you
thought was gonna like cut them down
calm down and just I just just go for it
right when they walk in the door amazing
so it was every I mean it was just I was
surprised that you didn't
um sort of comment on this ridiculous uh
onesie that I'm wearing well we've only
had one other person that's worn
something like that right Robbie
Williams
yeah but he dressed like a train
conductor bring up Robbie Williams you
look like damn Sling Blade unbelievable
you look like I've got to see this oh
yeah bring him up when he was on here if
you can he was really on this podcast
oh my God
we've basically dressed except I so he's
wearing a we're both wearing dungarees
but I look like I've grown through mine
like just an extra two foot up because
mine are lower
yeah but he came in I mean he definitely
looked like hey you're late for the
train you know he definitely came in
like he's got conductor on it written on
over yeah totally yeah he had kind of a
sling blade gets a job at Amtrak sort of
vibe going on I'm tracked with a with an
Apple Watch yeah yeah yeah definitely
not going to be late yeah
um but it was fast it was great I
haven't seen Robbie Williams in a long
time he looks great I think he's the
only other British person oh and Michael
Bisping oh wow so three Brit three
really interesting different British
people that we've had on here yeah
um yeah only three Brits I think so I'm
trying to think of maybe a different one
is that uh Max Moore was from Britain oh
Max Moore he does the um
cryonic freezing where they freeze
people oh god oh is he uh the freezer or
the freezee he is the freezer okay yeah
he's the freezer he's never been yeah I
think he would he himself is planning on
getting Frozen I think but it was just
interesting to learn he's never done it
himself I would never go to someone
who's never done it before there's only
one way to do it is to die
right it's that thing that's the thing
you have to die and then you go in wait
so he freezes people who are dead yeah
okay they catch them right when they're
about to that's why he's never done it
right yeah I got it so yeah there's only
one entry point right um it seems yeah
it seems Niche yeah yeah yeah
I guess he's I think that's a good way
to say it yeah
so what was it I'd love to know what his
chat was like is it I mean I could just
go and watch the podcast yeah what's his
name his name is Max Moore so he also is
named like a super villain type of name
m-a-x-m-o-r-e so he really lives this
you know when he looks bring a picture
of him up he looks like he's been damn
Frozen and thawed out 30 times he looks
like they wanted him for dinner and then
change their mind
but um he looks like Bill Burr like I
mean he's just been in like frozen yeah
there he is oh yeah
wow he looks like he really uh Wim Hoff
and Bilbo had a
heavy on the whim I think Hmm this dude
is uh but very interesting he's the he's
the the post
um he's the posthumist away isn't he
just with the freezing yeah he's doing
the same thing he keeps them all they
just you know they have all the bodies
and that sort of deal real interesting
if if things would win half go wrong
he's your guy I think and they freeze
him in like this different type of um
what was that stuff called Zach do you
remember
there's a certain type of gas I forget
the name of it
it's quite scary oh yeah scary uh but
his plan his thought is this that if
people like already they can take an
embryo right they can say if your
girlfriend wanted to donate eggs right
and then they froze those eggs which
they do for a lot of women now yeah so
they're basically freezing life
before so he's saying that they could
freeze you at the end also and then
later when they have the technology if
your DNA is still alive people are
hoping that you know we can get revived
like a mammoth right and he's saying why
not he goes at one point people thought
climbing up a ladder was as high as you
could get to something and then now we
you know we can travel through space so
100 that's really that is I mean I'm I
imagine that ladder was probably
invented after like uh some of the space
travel we've not space travel but maybe
oh the hypothesis just maybe the whole
airplane
yeah I didn't think about that I don't
really know which came first dude
imagine when somebody showed up with
that ladder bro damn
I mean one-eyed man in the Kingdom of
the blind oh
people imagine all the checks he got too
all those wrong Honeys yeah
I mean it would feel it feels like a
celebrity I imagined it locally yeah hey
he's coming over he's bringing it yeah
people with all things like on their
shelves or they can't reach people just
hiding stuff up way higher yeah yeah see
it look at him go just imagining
how his life panned out if he if he um
oh yeah you know the inventor of the
ladder like did he get royalties did he
get no I'm sure that's the dark side of
it then watching people go get stuff and
you know you're not making anything off
it yeah you're wandering around Curry
you know you're cursing at people who
are climbing up it could have been a
better older man I imagine oh I'd watch
that movie I'd watch about I'd watch
that there's a movie in it I think that
would be a very bad movie it'd be a
yeah a sad movie
I think you and I can make a really good
sad movie probably if you wanted I think
so I imagine yeah combine both of our
early lives yeah
so what what about your life do you was
a lot of your pressure from just like
acceptance or your peers because
obviously if you were kind of shy and
music was your
scapegoating you had these skills that
were kind of frowned upon which
certainly are in certain areas you know
um it makes you wonder how much
creativity has been really stifled by an
environment you know I think create I
think you know sometimes I thought it
was the singing the fact that you know
kids just didn't really but it's also a
bit like I think it's a bit like being a
footballer right you know when a kid
says I want to be a professional you
know soccer player when I'm older in
England that's like you know NFL here
you know it's this
almost unattainable dream that some
people do genuinely break through and
make it but it's you know if if a kid
says that's what they want to do you go
well people go like okay but have a
backup plan because probably not gonna
happen yeah and music's a bit like that
where it's like the odds are
you're not gonna be the
you're not going to be a superstar yeah
and you're probably not even going to
make it as high as you want to uh even
if you do become extremely successful
because it's never enough so ultimately
convincing people to
go into music for a living is is
actually slightly uh kind of a dubious
thing to suggest because it's it's
really hard and most people don't you
know make it uh but also there's also
loads of ways you can be involved in
music that don't you know um
don't have so much pressure on them and
you can make a living you can make a
great living for music and not be famous
and not be
in the band and not being that you know
you can be working music in so many
different ways
um but they're not the ways that people
focus on when they think of musician or
what they think of like the famous ones
um right right they're not some of the
most are like uh ways that are kind of
they're not the front man
yeah you think of the front front people
yeah I don't it's just advertising yeah
exactly yeah
um what other things do you think about
with music are there other worlds that
you like to conquer like you've had such
a you know you've gotten to work with
like Travis Scott and uh Beyonce you've
won a Grammy right for best rap
performance yeah was that right yeah I
mean
it was weird I was actually on the way
to the Grammys and they told me in the
car that I'd won one uh for best rap
performance and I so so essentially it's
on this
so on
so Kendrick Lamar uh-huh
we were supposed to work on he asked me
to work on the Black Panther stuff
the soundtrack and then also there was
this other song he was doing
which I think ended up on the Black
Panther soundtrack as well as King's
dead
and
I sent him this this thing it was going
to be like maybe a verse I don't really
know what it was but I tried something
on this song he wanted me to try to try
and be on it
anyway they ended up using like a very
very very small
clip of what I'd done it was like a
couple of seconds wow and putting a lot
of effects on it so I I wasn't
particularly audible or it wasn't
necessarily recognizably me now
obviously I don't care like that it
worked really well in the song like they
did a great job
um and I wasn't in any way like
cop about that like I just was like nice
to be included sample me call whatever
you want to do
but anyway they ended up putting my name
on the song as one of the features
now usually a feature is something like
someone does a verse or like that you
know whatever so anyway I'm this thing
uh and
I'm not
really playing a feature role but I'm my
name's on it
so I win a Grammy they win a Grammy for
the song and because my name's on the
actual song rather than just like buried
in the credits as a sample you get a
grandma I actually get a Grammy wow so
I've got uh and it says best rap
performance which in insinuates that I
rap which
um you can imagine I don't
dude that's crazy because sometimes you
would think man they put my name on here
I'm not even really on here just kind of
met some people might think this is kind
of messed up they're kind of using me
here but then it's funny how sometimes
things turn around and it's like oh here
you go I mean it's just funny it was
just a whole the whole situation was
funny like I didn't you know because we
ended up doing other songs yeah so it
was like if if that had been all they'd
used then maybe I could have felt a bit
sad about it but you know you've also
got to think like the man's a legend the
situation is legendary like the song
went was a hit it went multi-platinum
like I was just like cool like amazing
so I'm happy to be involved at all but
the uh yeah just the Grammy is funny I
mean it's currently hidden behind her
big modular synth
um in my studio
just poking out the back
when you have is your studio now fancier
than your studio when you first started
a little bit but it's still pretty much
the same principle just the keyboard
computer mic uh
it's just like
probably higher end versions of those
things but
quite simple quite small because
sometimes I think like is it hard to get
back to like them because sometimes we
look to our early stuff and like those
are the moments where I really wish I
could just still feel like myself you
know I even will have all podcast Clips
come up and I'm like oh man that's when
I was just really felt like
in the pocket of who I was as a person
before I started to take any input from
people's perspectives of me or before
stuff got out there and anybody knew who
I was and who I was was a secret to me
yeah and I was my it was like
it was almost like I had
some value for myself that once
everybody knows about it it's almost
like yeah you don't not still have it
but it's not yours as much anymore no
and you've and you've kind of shown your
it's on your cards showing your cards
basically yeah there's something there's
so there's something so special about
being a surprise yes definitely and and
the underdog and and like all these
things and like there was a time I
imagined where it felt like you were
people were just kind of discovering
your brain and how it works and kind of
going whoa never heard anyone say
anything like this or do anything like
this but
you know
that's a cool moment
but I think that your career especially
has kind of been littered with really
great moments that couldn't have
happened during that phase
like now you have this incredible fan
base of people who love the way your
brain works and know the way your brain
works and look for and look for
confirmation about how great you are and
and they they're like they're watching
because
they can count on you
to make them feel that thing that you
make them feel on and then also not just
laugh but also be understood and like
ask questions they're too afraid to ask
and
you know you you get to meet all these
people that they don't get to meet and
they can see it through your lens and
every new person you meet brings
something new out and you so there's
never
um there's never been a point at which
you were more capable of doing that than
right now um
it feels the other way though right
talking about in what way like do you
ever feel like I want oh God I wish I
could go back to whatever yeah but it's
a it's um but you can't get your brain
back there like your brain like yeah
your reality grows and you can't go back
you know yeah and I think
I think that's a good thing
because what you probably what we you
know I have a similar thing you know I
look back at some of my old music and I
think like
oh like I was thinking so much simpler
back then or I really knew how to do
this or like I didn't overcomplicate or
you know they were oh yeah like I really
had a fire in my belly for this type of
thing right and
that's cool but that moment really only
lasted for however long it lasted and
then right after that I had to and I was
finding a fire for other things and
I think
obviously we can't revisit moments in
time but what we can do
is make sure that our head is clear and
that we're on our path because I think
the feeling that we miss
the feeling of being on our path ah it's
not necessarily
the thing we were doing at the time we
were on our part that we were on our
path yeah it's
I am doing
what I'm here to do
but I'm exactly where I should be in the
universe
and
I am being so I mean being integral
I'm not letting other people's opinions
get to me I'm
pursuing what it is I love
I'm being authentic and I'm
enjoying every moment and I'm and I'm
being present
when you feel those things
the content you put out
is going to be
great
and it will always be a moment people
look back on because ultimately the
thing that brought you to where you are
now sorry into even into you know public
consciousness
was the fact that you were on that path
uh your every essence your actual
Essence is why you're there right it's
every it's the way you look at the world
it's all the things that led to this
it's your childhood it's the thing the
ways that you learn to
um
kind of put those experiences into words
or the way you learned to you know find
those
so it's not like getting back to a
certain dock it's just like being
still just
be in the Stream kind of or getting it's
like that in Flow State right it's
finding flow State ah because I always I
always mess up and think it's oh I gotta
get back to this dock but it's like no
that doc was just part of something you
passed by as you were in a comfortable
healthy self that was part of the
scenery right I believe I mean that's
what I believe anyway this is I'm this
is uh I'm always looking out the window
thinking oh I got to get back to where
the car passed but yeah really I just
have to get back into this comfortably
in the driver's seat wow I think so
I think so yeah and it's such a fight to
try and think how do I get back there
you know and then you're always working
from A Loss because it's impossible it's
the it's the kind of con it's the
Buddhist concept of uh you know desire
is suffering it's like
if you if you want what you don't
currently
embody then
you are starting from a point of deficit
you don't have the thing so therefore
you know wanting something equals
unhappiness
but
I mean that's I think no it's good it's
cool I have to pee really bad to you I
really do all right let's pee and then
we'll come back and maybe talk about
some news thanks for releasing me would
you ever uh and you got it gets much
colder in uh Britain huh much colder
yeah wow well actually I say that I mean
America's a big place and
it gets much colder in Minnesota than it
does anywhere in England oh do you ever
feel like you've sold out your country
by moving out of it
interesting
and maybe that's not the best term to
you that's no general term no I mean
it's definitely like a what you know as
an English person it's definitely like a
concern that you in some way have
insulted your you know your own by
moving out but
no
I never felt like I lived anywhere to be
honest I do feel English I mean all my
cultural reference points are English
and all my comedy uh
comedy references and musicals any
brightness would find roots of you there
you'd be busted there exactly but that's
interesting music music a lot of it was
American and a lot of like other like
Japanese and uh like European uh music
and you know just you know loads of
different cultural influences that uh
were not English and and also
I think on a spiritual level I just
didn't really resonate with nationality
particularly I didn't really have a
national pride particularly or you know
being English being English is is
complex isn't it and it's you know it
comes with a history that's not
necessarily
um you know some of it's great and some
of it's quite shameful and yeah some of
it you'd you know I don't understand why
I would
really attach myself to the positive or
the negative of my country's history
when I wasn't part of it
yeah it's interesting you know with
history it's interesting because it's
like people it's easy to look back on
history and be like oh this is you know
this wasn't good you know from present
perspectives and stuff like that and and
you know I'm sure at the time a lot of
British people were like we're taking
over the world you know it was like a
different like there was probably a
pride that would seem foolish now if
somebody had it you know like oh yeah it
seem you know it's just interesting how
time gives shape to things because all
of our sort of uh reach of power is kind
of just like slowly and now we're just
this little island uh that
has you know a lot of cultural power and
I guess some Financial power but I we're
we're definitely
um
maybe got a tail between our legs a
little bit uh might might account for
some of the self-deprecation that
happens yeah I think maybe a historical
tale between your legs maybe I'm curious
to see like how does Britain kind of
like
how do they feel okay to show their
still show who they are or find who they
are I think with a little bit of
difficulty actually I think I think like
when you have a national kind of sense
of like something you know when we're
not like we've not always been part of
you know the you know the British Empire
like the colonialism we're we're you
know I think finding pride has to come
from other obviously other sources
unless you genuinely are proud of that
in which case
I don't know how I can't help you but
but that
this this side of being English like the
comedy the the kind of
um the music the culture
the El cultural output of England is
really amazing I mean I I look back at
you know a lot of my biggest influences
have also been uh English bands
um it's funny I mean I I didn't actually
really wasn't really um
like a fan of Oasis at the time but I
went to I'm a big Beatles fan
um lots of lots of bands kind of eluded
me until I was a bit older because I
mostly listened to piano based music and
and like Mozart
yeah whether it was classical or I
listened to
um a lot of like
like Soul classical
[Music]
um Japanese kind of ambient type like
Kabuki or something is that like uh I
don't know what that is but
um I don't either
so but like yeah but but no I mean it
could be a genre though I something I
don't know about but uh yeah I mean
um raiuchi Sakamoto is a good good uh
example you should listen to me I think
you like him very calming oh really
beautiful oh I could use that right
right yeah you bring him up let's see an
image of them
I want to see a JPEG of this fella
ryuki ryuchi ryuchi oh I love Japanese
people man
I went to Japan one time and
we took a bunch of ice creams with us to
the park and we gave them the kids and
took pictures of them eating them
I mean beautiful man oh God he is he
looks like my mother a little in the
face not in the hair actually if her if
his hair was a lot longer yeah right
oh yes he looks like a composer doesn't
he I mean
just just a legend I'd love to be
Japanese I think it feels like
everything's just so damn organized
inside of you you know I feel like you
swallow water and it immediately is
ready to be yours it's immediately yeah
efficiently processed oh there's no
doubt there's not all this Milling
around you know right because I'm going
through the kidneys get out of here with
that BS straight through it's just right
yes that's it yes it seems just like
here we go I mean fit into a shirt size
I feel like if you're Japanese you fit
in there is no like you're in the middle
okay this looks bad on me you know I
feel like you are there's a definite
there's a there's a definable like when
you go to Tokyo for example there's a
definable style
uh identity yeah and I've found that
some of the most stylish people I've
ever met have been Japanese and some of
the most stylish kind of like ideas in
clothing have been come from I mean this
is actually I mean I'm not to say that
this is I'm not saying I'm sorry I think
this is like
one of the well it is and it is by um
it's by uh
um
yojiyamamoto but uh I wear a lot of
Japanese clothes because I just think
they
that will I mean
Yamamoto and isimiyaki are like my
favorite designers wow yeah and and you
know going back to when I was a kid yeah
lots of lots of Japanese music and and I
think
I was also fascinated by like
in like Western and Japanese crossovers
um
and
um
just
like the the intersection between those
sounds and one thing you find is that
every
every culture has its kind of own chord
uh kind of or tonality what's the word
sort of like World of notes that that
sound good together in that you know
style so for example uh
in French music right so like French uh
early classical or whatever it's like
there's a
there's a there's a world of tone that
kind of
sounds French if you know what you're
listening to for
um
and when you go to the when you go to
the Eurostar which is funny there's
there's a sound that plays it's like
whatever it's like a it's like a thing
and it's the most French
notes oh interesting that have ever been
written yeah that's funny if you know a
lot about music you're probably able to
hear a lot of different like little just
things in the world and know like Trace
them back yeah it's almost like Latin
like if you know sounds it's almost like
when you learn Latin that's interesting
everything's rooted in something yeah
yeah well you know when you go to
Japan there's a lot of sounds in like
train stations and [ __ ] that they have
and you just go wow this isn't I mean
nothing like anything that I'm I'm used
to and it's kind of amazing
um do you think
um
do you notice any difference between the
audiences like in different places like
in some of the behavior of them and
stuff like Japan's a really interesting
place to play because uh the a lot of
the audiences are they're like super
respectful
at least for the shows that we've put on
they'll be completely silent during the
music and then erupt in like the loudest
possible Applause and then as soon as
they sense that you're ready to start
the next song complete silence again
like penny drop wow that's crazy does it
feel crazy it feels or does it feel like
right
you know what it's just different it's
like it feels right there
but it's so
I can understand the logic behind it
and there's a such respect that comes
with that it's like they really really
respect the art and what you're doing
and also we were there you know we're
kind of we don't go there very often so
and you're not you know if you go too
often I think they probably get bored of
you and you start to seem domestic
almost but they respond especially like
that I think to people who are from out
of town who come in and just kind of um
more of a rarity it's like they just
really want to be present for the
I don't want to miss it yeah we want to
be in the moment yeah maybe they value
the moment a bit more maybe there's some
more of a
value for the moment they have so much
history
well I wonder if it's also we're over in
America politeness
people over here hey dude quit [ __ ]
the moment it's like we're just people
over here just you know just being
yeah just like the moment's uh it's like
there's millions of moments right
there's so many moments that it's it's
kind of expansive and we've kind of had
that in America like we got unlimited
moments you know exactly but now I think
we're start I think things are starting
to change a little bit and it's like man
we need to Value this moment the economy
of moments basically it's like we are
now in a moment where we
don't have that many like live
interactive experiences so I would think
that people are starting to go when they
go to comedy shows or whatever they're
probably paying a little bit more you
know they're like feel a bit more
grateful to be there feel a bit more
grateful to like have access to someone
in real life after just spending a
pandemic not being able to see anyone
not being able to go out
apart from in uh Tennessee obviously uh
but like the fact that someone is stood
in front of you and they've spent their
whole life perfecting this art form and
then you go there and then you just talk
all over it I mean the idea of doing
that after the pandemic seemed
seemed more insane than it did before
because
it would seem ungrateful like well
especially with music I mean you guys
the people are more likely to be able to
party and stuff during your shows and
have fun you know with comedy you're
really people have to kind of sit and
listen for the most part yeah although a
lot of people shush other people in my
shows oh they do which annoys me oh so I
actually hates it
like or tell me what happens what do you
mean well I'll be playing something and
and I'm in the middle of a song and
someone just goes like you know they'll
say something
crowd-like you know like uh all right
yeah yeah yeah well I love you yeah and
I'm like in my brain I'm like I love you
too but I don't can't say anything
because I'm doing your work
damn I think and
someone else just shot just goes
I'm just and you're like
what it says the thing is I always feel
like responsible for what they've just
done because I feel like maybe something
I put across maybe it's just an
insecurity but I feel like something I
put across
has made them feel like I wouldn't like
it oh that's interesting you know I
wouldn't like it if someone like
expresses how excited they are or
whatever
oh I feel like oh yeah I want you to
think that they're a warden for me I
feel like some kind of like yeah like
real like stick up my ass [ __ ] dude I
used to feel that way about girl like
girls I would date and stuff I didn't
want any girl to be like a reflection of
me so it'd be like if they made a
mistake or like I used to date this one
girl who had no like beautiful really
sweet girl she had no sense of like
spatial awareness right she would just
be like you know talking to you and like
she'd bump in a 65 people somehow like
just while she was talking
she's a Dodge him we call them Dodgers
yeah and it's one of those you know like
the uh cars that bump into each other in
yeah the fairground yeah yeah yeah she
was just like gee like oh my God don't
you know somebody's right behind you she
would always turn and knock over a damn
glass or a top hat off of somebody you
know yeah and it would just like it
drove me what would you do in that it
just me because I didn't want her to be
a reflection of who I it would be like
yeah yeah I didn't want anybody thinking
like oh man it's such a narcissistic
thing really he he endorses he's like
right cool with this right which makes
him also as as kind of unwieldedly and
uh [ __ ] you know uncool or whatever
yeah not cool in some way ultimately it
comes back to I'm not accepted or like
right but you know the I and I thought I
did exactly the same thing but with with
uh with like social interactions and
like if somebody said the wrong thing
I'd prickle up and like feel really
tense and like wanna probably it'll come
out with a little comment towards them
at some point you know later or even
during the conversation and I just
couldn't hide it I was so uncomfortable
with somebody else [ __ ] up
because ultimately like the school I
went to was just like people were so
hard on each other if some if someone
[ __ ] up ah right so you just developed
this thing of like no one must say
anything wrong no one could come into
the situation with an energy that
doesn't match everyone else no one can
and it's like it's such a like
you know uh restrictive
place to live that and I just would
emanate that is that a very British
thing you think or is it just you it is
yeah for sure yeah but also just I think
it's just the way I grew up yeah school
I went to was like that it was a very
the school I went to was like quite
it was it was a school where you had to
take a test to get in but it was free
yeah so so it wasn't like a private
school but it was for kids who excelled
and did stuff yeah it was for kids who
essentially came from all man as a
background but
had a certain level of of reading
comprehension or whatever it was like
they tested you on multiple different
things
and so it was a good school to be at
because it had like kind of like a
culturally like there was a lot of
different cultures but it was very
intellectual it was all about
intellectual sparring and like
when kids are like
in some ways I'd prefer to have been
beaten up than psychologically bullied
you know because at least then I could
have had a chance to like hit someone
right and get my anger out
I don't know maybe I'm not really sure
what's worse but when kids are like
super manipulative and like a bit able
to like find your button and like fully
[ __ ] [ __ ] the button and then just
kick and just keep [ __ ] it until
you're just like not able to defend
yourself you know it's like that
that is uh like a different stock and I
think it puts you in this like
psychological like defense for the rest
of your life oh yeah unless you fix it I
mean I just took [ __ ] ages to like
get rid of that thing of like if someone
says something or if I say the worst
honestly the worst case scenario would
be I say something and then in my mind
like everyone just like turns around
it's just like
why right what the [ __ ] did you just say
you know everything stops can you
imagine it's like record
and I want to stop the music yeah right
and then
oh and it's awkward that was like my
worst nightmare basically which is funny
is it it's a pretty tame worst nightmare
to have
but it's but it's what happens in that
environment it's a psychological
Thriller yeah which you just shared you
know yes psychological Thriller it's
just not me yeah um yeah I think there's
definitely a like I uh speaking of
psychological thrillers I got a clip
what you got man a song broke out at a
psych ward
oh my God they all broke out singing in
songs with three this is it now
insurance barely probably even cover
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
say
[Music]
they got my vote what party are they
running with this is UN like this is not
living in my house I mean I live with
three people so this is basically our
house oh wow really yeah from all
different rooms oh you do yeah well I
mean yeah I live with uh two of my best
friends and and Jamila yeah um and we're
just yeah
wow it's a very it's kind of a modern
thing I wonder it's it's interesting how
stuff like like
I wonder if we're getting to this let
place in the world where it's like um
I don't know what I'm trying to say it's
like we need like
Everything feels very vigilante now
it's like the person who's gonna like
it's like the world feels kind of like
the wild west you mean like
individualistic like people are just
kind of EX just doing
they've kind of gone [ __ ] it I've given
up on society I'm just gonna they might
do it my own way this is the fabric of
American society I feel like quickly
unravel like Betsy Ross is like the
stitching somehow over the past five
years has come out right right and I
don't know if a lot of people are buying
into the this American ideal anymore
interesting I don't know if they're not
I just don't know I'm this is also like
in Los Angeles right now you don't get a
really clear idea I mean
um but Los Angeles is a very very
unclear picture of of uh or at least
Hollywood yeah Hollywood that's an
extremely unclear picture of like
people's interaction in general because
if so much of it is
incentivized by success or power or fame
uh or in some way somebody's like desire
or drive
to to like
to achieve something
then obviously things just they're not
they're not as they they're not as pure
as just they're not pure basically
whereas I think most places are not like
that I mean and also
you know that is just speaking for an
industry rather than like Los Angeles as
a whole because Los Angeles as a whole
is multifaceted yeah it's cultural I
forget that a lot too A lot of times
I'll say Los Angeles instead of really I
just mean Hollywood
um
or there are is there like other genres
and stuff that you see where you would
see yourself going into music is there
anything that feels off limits do you
feel like you're kind of have your
horizons of even possibility brought
broad broadened over time over the years
or anything or do you
uh yeah I mean I start doing
I'm doing a thing like a film bit film
music at the moment
so scoring a film yeah scoring a kind of
visual thing
um I I call it a film but it's not a
kind of um movie in the way that like a
it's not a
um
you know the master or something or like
a [ __ ] narrative Driven movie it's a
kind of more of a visual thing
um but I'm really excited about it and
I hope that it leads to more of that and
I want to do narrative movies as like
proper me you know that kind of thing
um
weird that my music is
seen as so atmospheric but that I've not
really ever been involved in kind of
scoring and stuff but you have wanted to
for a while
and um
yeah I feel like yeah your music does
feel like that I feel like I'm
hitchhiking through my own feelings kind
of sometimes a little bit yeah yeah or
I'm hitchhiking through your feelings
yes I feel like somebody's kind of
hitchhiking through my feelings um
and you're picking them up
sometimes or not sometimes I'm just
watching them just being like I don't
know I have to listen more I think it
just kind of depends on whatever feeling
I'm in at that moment what are the
feelings that you
kind of like when you listen to music
like what when when do you listen to
music and I listen music for one when I
need a pick-me-up I'll listen to certain
songs yeah there's a couple of songs
I'll listen to uh I think when I want to
feel something I'll listen to some other
stuff
um you know I was into comedy when I
need to pick me up I think yeah yeah
because yeah because music is I guess
the thing the thing is with our jobs is
that they they become
they become jobs oh totally people are
like what are your hobbies I'm like I
don't have my heart but my hobbies
became my job right and now and now it's
neither yeah and it's so now I have to
find out things outside so outside of
music and comedy what what do you like
do you as someone who you I you I mean I
feel like we're so similar in so many
ways
when you look at the world of people
going and experiencing things like you
know someone's skydiving and somebody's
going surfing like do you ever go past
the sea and watch people surfing and go
God I wish I could just like
be in the world like that the way they
are oh yeah I think that all the time
it's hard for it's for there's something
about it that's tough for me I think
sometimes I did comedy I want to be the
person in the crowd having a good time I
want to be the one laughing you like uh
when uh when yay said uh
oh boy knows Kanye West said um
I you know my my greatest regret is that
I would never be able to see myself
perform live
um that seems Seems like an egotistical
thing to say but I think in in some ways
it articulates something that a lot of
performers feel
um
not necessarily present at their own
shows
and actually they want to be part more
part of the feeling that everyone else
is having than they are of the feeling
they're having yeah I think forever I
never went to any comedy or listened
much at all you know I did I think I
didn't want to be influenced and I think
I was just so stuck in my own little
world yeah I didn't want anything to
mess up my world or anything to
influence it you know I just valued my
own little creative space so much really
almost too much it kept me isolated but
yeah I didn't
um I didn't want to have uh any real
influences outside of myself and
sometimes I thought yeah I wish I could
be the person laughing at the show yeah
if I can't be at least I'll be as the
closest I can to that person will be
someone at least making the humor yeah
totally it's like at least then I'm part
of the equation that's how I felt about
music so how I felt about uh DJing uh as
well because like I always felt really
self-conscious about dancing and like
expressing myself in those ways and also
I'm very tall I'm very you know I mean I
wouldn't say I'm out of before out of
proportion but I but I'm a long fella
but I'm a long person and I and I my
limbs you get shot first in Army exactly
I'd be you know what's that movie where
they they a wire comes across the ship
and all the people are taller than a
certain height get immediately killed oh
damn ghost ship
um I'd be gone in the first scene and
then also I'm you know like a we call
them daddy long legs but they're like
mayflies or whatever those those little
insects that have like those really long
legs and they just sort of like bumble
around like not
knocking into stuff that's me
at like a rave or you know something so
I I just I like I'm I always feel
slightly uncomfortable like never I'm
always knocking into people like oh [ __ ]
did I knock it and then you know back to
you know losing myself I can never quite
lose myself in the moment sometimes yeah
I can never lose myself completely man
right I find that some so I uh I find
that DJing is like an amazing way of
like not having to
just not having to contend with any of
that stuff and instead I can just stand
there and be worshiped like a god no no
I can be just
present the music that everyone just
gets you know gets to do that too yeah
and then I'm then on at least my excuse
can be that well I can't be down there
at the same time right so yeah at least
you have an excuse yeah are they
attention no one can come up to me and
make some small talk that I can't hear
because it's too loud and then I don't
have there's no chance of me like saying
something dumb to someone
or like not
you know not having a cool social
interaction I can just stand up there
and people can assume that I'm cool
because I'm deep because I'm a DJ
but I'm actually not
and I never have to reveal that
yeah it's like if you're in that space
it kind of keeps you safe from
everything
Fleet bubble yeah it's amazing it's such
a it's such a control and people give
DJs such a you know it's like a
mythology it's like crazy I mean you
must think even that's crazy 100 and and
they pay them way more than they should
I don't know what's happening DJing is
like the I don't know how that works
it's it's honestly
yeah it feels exorbitant have you been
to festivals and stuff where it's just
like DJ festivals and stuff yeah oh wow
yeah so sometimes do you just DJ and
sometimes you play your music I DJ I
actually love DJ it's like um uh for me
there's so I mean there's such a craft
to it and it's so deep like it's great a
great DJ is like uh
you know controlling the vibe of the
entire place and like can be in tune
with but genuinely in tune with the
crowd and like it's a it's a real
[Music]
um
you know you can go into a set not
knowing at all what you're going to play
and just and just watch the crowd and
figure out how you're gonna
like you're you're coming on after the
next the DJ before you and you're
watching how they're playing to the
crowd and you're seeing what works
and then you're going okay what's in my
record bag that I can you're back in the
day I'd play vinyl yeah and so I'd be
you know just kind of acting on it's
real in the moment decisions like this
tune is in the right key or it's in the
right Tempo it's in the right it's the
right vibe to come on to to follow on
from the last thing and like oh this one
will get them like this one will get
them dancing or this one it's like that
feeling is like hey
you're kind of living through them
vicariously you're like experiencing
that hype and that fun
with them and through them and then you
can kind of like kind of pretend you're
at your own show at the same time
and it's
it's like psychological and it's it's
also
you're getting to hear all your favorite
music and like so it's just it's
brilliant yeah my friend satchfield's a
DJ down in New Orleans and he's one of
my best friends from growing up and I
get to watch him like you know how he
looks at a group of people and like you
know you can see the wheels start
turning and it's red and like and he
knows so much music's here you start to
think like you start to see him grin and
kind of like all right what's gonna the
cogs are turning yeah yeah sure yeah
um
what else what else happened in the News
Zach anything else interesting out there
uh yeah we were talking about this it's
a pretty American story uh Philadelphia
man and just ate a rotisserie chicken
every day for 40 days oh wow he doesn't
recommend it he's on the uh the the
um Jordan Payson diet yeah oh I went to
dinner with Jordan Peterson man and uh
during the pandemic with him and his
daughter
oh yeah and her boyfriend and they
ordered told me all meat and brother at
the end of the meal there's literally a
plate of bones in the middle of the
table it very much had like this Game of
Thrones type of vibe and no no asparagus
no vegetables
need I think somebody had sparkling
water and they even frowned at him a
little whoever it was
other people had flat water but somebody
bubbled up and everybody was like you
[ __ ] yeah that just went but in the end
it looked like a plate like a batch of
looking a batch of dogs had been there
just to play I'll have to put some
pictures and I have that I uh
you've done anything like that I've
never done 40 days of eating whole
chickens but I've
um
I mean I'm vegetarian so it's not
something
it's not a sport I can really
participate he didn't really have a
reason which is my criticism he just
said he's doing it to bring people
together so I don't I mean judging by
that picture it did bring a lot of
people together I wonder what
this looks like Yeah The Last Supper
like an Albertsons yeah he's like the
high priest of
chickenating
yeah that's a very reminisce this looks
like a lot of like a like a pre-party
for a Renaissance fair
I feel like it looks like it looks like
a paint a resin painting yes it does huh
yeah it actually would be really cool if
somebody made like a nice painting of
that you know the right accessory you
can Channel I mean there's a lot of
great bits of Art in here I think you
should challenge your listeners to to
paint this because it's a
It's a Wonderful scene oh it's
remarkable actually the 40th Day of
rotisserie chicken I wonder how many of
those I wonder if that crowd grew over
the 40 days to this I imagine it didn't
start this way
his girlfriend probably left him I'm
sure after day eight or something of her
being lonely well I imagine the smell oh
there you go got um quite overwhelming
and there he is and it seems very
perverse I think there's something uh
yeah there's something edible or
something going on
yeah something like that okay I don't
even really know what that means but did
you ever work at a uh food place James I
never worked at a food place now did you
ever although I did I did I did one time
uh do a job at a festival where I was
part of catering stuff oh yeah
um and they gave us a uh one baked
potato oh for lunch for lunch and dinner
that was what we had it was one book toe
which I thought was unreasonable
to say the least I mean it was a they
weren't they didn't give you any butter
or anything it was just you you queued
up for a baked potato and that was your
softness for the day every British Ray I
feel like has like some mild starvation
somewhere in it I feel like there's like
such a some self-punishment or like some
kind of there's such bad launching it
was like four have you ever seen the
four Yorkshire men sketch I'll have to
play that too basically it's a bunch of
people
sitting around being like you know
where we are when we grew up we didn't
have a pot to piss in you know we didn't
blah blah and then the other guy's like
yeah well I mean we didn't even have a
house we lived in a ditch blah blah blah
you know and when our dad came home he'd
beat us around the head was like oh you
were lucky the other guy's like you were
lucky we had a you know our dad would
come home and stab us and we'd live in a
pond you know anyway so that's that's
like
but it's like a classic uh I mean I'm
really miss no but is it but it's a it's
a classic English sketch and that's kind
of what the the baked potato thing sort
of like conjures really it's this like
Stark uh
just you know scarcity mentality
situation where
but but then it's at a festival where
everyone's having loads of fun
um yeah everybody's all geeked up on uh
Molly eating baked potatoes yeah well I
mean they were all eating you know from
food trucks and like oh yeah so we were
just but anyway so I I worked there and
and um but that was only for two days
and I got fired I think because I just
wasn't
I wasn't I just I felt away about the
potatoes I just felt like it wasn't
enough
and I'm obviously very tall I was always
I was always tall I was tall then oh
so it's hard being that tall guy I feel
like remember the one kid that would
come back from Summer tall and everybody
like what look at this [ __ ] yeah
you know people are like oh look at this
show off you know that was me what does
he think he's doing uh look at this guy
with his [ __ ] ass little cervical spine
yeah yeah yeah you know and they start
saying all that kind of [ __ ] they did
say that kind of [ __ ] and I just I just
took it and then I learned to love my
height over time but it started yeah I
hated being tall I really hated her oh I
think it would be such an adventure but
it would be very interesting when you
put your arm out of the bed and it just
touches the floor it Pets the cat if
it's down there yeah what about instead
of hitting your head on stuff oh and
then you hate your [ __ ] head I I
there's a number of times I mean it
probably accounts for some of my
personality now what about love a lot of
your song there's definitely a lot of
loss a lot of like Jesus huh somewhere
else some girl some girl left this guy
at the day old bread store you know yes
um where did some of that come from like
where does where do you think some of
that comes from well
my first record I'd never been in love
and or if I had it'd be unrequited so I
was I lost my opportunity very late I
was very late bloomer
and uh so I was just like 20 years old
20 22 23
. pretty late I mean in this country
that's probably not as uncommon because
maybe because of religious reasons
um but with the exchange rate of
virginity is really I think it's
probably about one to one 0.6 to one
when it comes to like British to
American yeah
um
so like what the dollar to the pound
used to be oh yeah
um and I
just
didn't I was always very ashamed of that
at the time that you hadn't lost it yet
but I hadn't yeah and I and I was also
wasn't like I wasn't in the game oh so
you were really on the sideline I was
really on the sidelines just kind of
being like people will be talking about
sex and I'd be like yeah I mean yeah I
mean totally like vaginas for sure for
sure like I get it man yeah it must be
it's man you'd be wearing Like a Man
City Jersey just talking about it like
this yeah for sure yeah [ __ ] like horse
yeah sex always I know what you're
talking about
um wow so you were really on the
satellites just of like kind of like a
lot of social stuff kind of or yeah I
think so I was the thing I was just a I
was an outsider in a lot of ways and uh
because that gives you a lot of time to
observe stuff and see it yeah but I was
also like I was kind of semi-popular in
other ways like I was I was always
like a bit of a
I was always a bit of a Class Clown and
I was I I got in trouble a lot and I was
always very
kind of insolent and like not
I don't know if I was acting out because
I thought it was cool or because I
thought it was
I genuinely had a lot of like
uh like I I was um anti-establishment
yeah in general like I just felt
I just felt I sort of felt like I wasn't
supposed to be at school as well I
always felt like I was supposed to be
you know
um
in music somewhere doing something else
or doing something else you just I just
knew that I wasn't supposed to I knew I
didn't need Science school probably
always felt very nervous to you I knew I
didn't need to learn French right it
probably felt nervous to you
um in a in a strange way it didn't feel
it didn't feel like beneath me or it
didn't feel it didn't feel like I I
didn't feel like I was too smart for it
or I didn't feel like I just thought I
just thought
I don't need these skills I don't
because I know where I'm going and I
don't need any of this stuff oh yeah
what I need is
to get older yeah
I just need to be 10 years older and
then I'll have what I want interesting
and also there was this thing I can't
remember what it's got like Alpha
personality basically where
you have this thing where you're like in
the future I'm gonna get everything I
always wanted so it's okay that I'm
suffering now
you know so it's this delusional kind of
thing of like I've got my eyes on the
prize
and so you can all like
you can all laugh right but I'm gonna be
this
I'm gonna you know be a 23 year old
virgin uh and
so I um I move this mic down just a
touch oh yeah sorry you're good or just
down a little yeah there we go
um sorry it's my it's my first time on a
on a podcast oh yeah I'm happy to have
you man oh no I did I did jamila's but I
could you know I mean yeah you have to
I mean what are you gonna know I'm not
gonna do this podcast I thought I had a
chance with her dad I didn't even know I
was dropping her off at your house
you thought it was a long career in
podcasting with her ahead of you
um what uh what else do we have what
else is in the news oh wait so did you
first time you fell in love then so what
was that like
it was really amazing I mean I did wait
I waited and it wasn't I didn't do it in
a kind of um like a religious sense but
I think there was a spiritual component
to it I think I was waiting for someone
I trusted I think I was waiting for
someone I had a spiritual connection
with
um
but actually in the end I lost lost my
virginity to someone ran someone kind of
random or I had no connection with at
all
um but the relationship I ended up in
was one it was great yeah yeah some
someone really wonderful and and um and
then
I only had one more relationship after
that and that's the one I'm in um so
that brings us up to now but um yeah and
you guys have been in love for a long
time
eight years wow
it's about eight years
um
that's cool that's rare yeah it is
um she's incredible and
you know it I guess it does feel
like we've it just always feels like
we've been together a year which is kind
of amazing that's kind of a cool lyric
or something like that you know oh yeah
it is
although you know
people are people are strange about
listening to
love songs about someone you're actually
with
I don't know why that is
oh that's true if that's the case it
almost becomes a little bit
yeah does it take on more of a country
music Vibe then sometime a little bit I
should become a country artist
and then people would accept the love
songs you're actually with yeah because
there's something about your songs I
want you to not be with the person you
mean you want me to be completely
[ __ ] heartbroken I want the person to
be as lonely as I probably am feeling or
it's like you know you want there to be
some of that and look James's music is
in all lonely music if you haven't heard
it it's all it's all types of stuff but
it's a nice way to want I find it it's
it's it's it changes a lot but it's it's
um there's all different it's all to yes
yeah yeah but let's go check it out but
I did become known for like a very you
know
um
a period in my life where I wrote a lot
of the music that I became known for was
a time of immense sadness and loneliness
for me so I mean I guess it came out
sounding
a little bit full on and a little bit
that but also at the same time it's
uplifting music at the same time because
it's like it's a bit like um
a bit like with Radiohead for example
there's certain bands who Through Time
have have got the criticism
of sad or as if that's criticism I don't
know why but you know sad or doubt or
depressing or whatever and I think
that's just a reflection of whoever is
listening most of the time I mean
something can sound dreary
and on some day be dreary and on another
day be completely uplifting it just
depends what your mood is and how it's
and also
I would never want to like I'd never
want to uh discourage and I hate
language that discourages people from
listening to music that gives them
emotional release like that's why I had
such a problem with the sad boy time and
like when I would I'd get written about
in in like Publications like you know
certain Publications basically who'd
write
you know like one of the things was like
he needs to maybe should get out more or
like I was just like you don't get it
like you don't get that there are people
who feel the same thing as I feel right
who are listening to this processing
stuff right
and by this language what you're saying
is like
don't do that ah yeah and you might be
you might actually be taking away
someone's emotional comfort blanket that
makes their life way harder
you know it's funny I think that's an
honest too about like someone's on this
podcast I'll talk about feelings and
things that I've had over the years and
sometimes I feel like it gets
it's tough because I have to I have to
walk this line I don't want to get to
Melancholy yeah I don't want to get or
actually I don't care if I get
Melancholy but I don't want to get where
I am in self-pity like self-indulgent
right and it can happen it's really
tough it's tough because you don't
notice it happening you think you're
just exploring it more right and and it
can and it can certainly
um it can certainly happen I think with
with music though it's interesting
because it's like music and musicians
they let us feel something that we can't
say it's like man this you'll see
somebody who won't even talk probably to
their wife or something but then they'll
they'll both it get there and sing a
song together yeah or dance to us it's
like well that video of everyone's
singing yeah the people trapped in the
middle Hospital singing Katy Perry you
know whatever I Want It That Way
Backstreet Boys yeah yeah I mean you
know and then to some extent there is
some truth in you know like the our
parents generation would just be like no
don't talk about it but like just come
on man you don't need to go to therapy
just
crack on
carry on yeah you'll be all right just
you know just like get their pale walk
up the hill yeah just just just
um you know to some extent like talk
about it to a friend but other than that
just get on with it and you know you'll
you'll be uh you can push through it and
and even the British are cracking now
Patty pimlet had a freaking outspoken
speech remember a couple of fights ago
what was that oh no like my mate oh yeah
yeah you know it's like yeah you saw
that Brit you know that was really
moving yeah it was just you know it's
like yeah I think we're also like
there's just an humanity is this energy
of nature it's this path of nature yeah
we don't really know what it is yet yeah
that's true and
I think we've you know when you look at
how much feeling and stuff is in there
at a certain point it's got to come out
like it is it has and then but then I
think what you're touching on is quite
interesting because it's like we're not
there is a certain point at which it's
not productive anymore
and you know I think that
coming to an un a balance between our
generation maybe and the generation
before us or couple before us a balance
between those two mentalities of like
you know maybe self-victimization
on our account or kind of going over the
same things over and over again yeah and
not realizing you're in a cycle
or a pattern or just kind of like
focusing so much on the trauma that
you're not actually a kind of paying
attention to like actual real life
practices that can help you or like yeah
Forward Motion forward momentum like the
fact that achievement actually genuinely
does you know can be a good motivation
or you know like General
um kind of yeah like
positive thinking like lots of you know
it's like you can just dwell on things
and we have uh a you know there is a
school of thought that says
being in constant kind of term kind of
uh digging up of things is a good is is
like important I think there's a balance
to be struck yeah and the the kind of uh
wisdom in the older Generations
sometimes is that um
that we
there is a lot of common common uh
commonality to be found between people
and there are differences sometimes are
not always worth dwelling on
and that we are
we are strong
capable
uh people who can
[ __ ] get it done get it done yeah get
basically persevere take care of
ourselves yeah sometimes we have to come
to our own rescue you start to realize
that too it's like there's self-help
stuff it starts to create sometimes too
much of a world where you're always
trying to help yourself yeah and you're
reading up and taking in so much stuff
about you know inspirational but you're
not actional and also that's an industry
that's a people are profiting off right
or your your constant engagement with
self-help your constant engagement it's
like at a certain point it's like are
you okay yeah you know if you're not you
know I think that we I always encourage
being uh aware of your emotions and
trying to delve into them and like
figure them out
um but I think
there is a there is a certain point
where
it's time to rejoin
the world and try and Float yeah I mean
you'll yeah I find you will if you sit
there and they're feeling long enough
looking around inside of it and looking
at the reading the graffiti and [ __ ]
you'll then that's where you're gonna
live you know I start to realize it's
like you know they always say you can
act your way in a positive thinking but
you can't think your way into positive
action you know right and that's
something I have to come back to because
I like to dwell I like to wander around
in the in the um in the art museum of my
childhood and of my like things that
meant something to me and like my first
kiss in the first like mistakes I made
and like I like to wander on and look at
all the artifacts and yeah things but
you can't live in the museum you can't
yeah yeah and is it time to shut it off
and leave the museum yeah there's a um I
can't remember but I think it's my
girlfriend just talking about like
you know being in this hole and just
like painting the walls and it's just
now it's just a beautiful hole it's like
which now sounds
but no it's semi-sexual in a way that I
didn't want it to but that's you know
that is right to some extent it like
sums up where you can get to where you
can draw the map perfectly of how your
emotions have of your emotional state
you can become so obsessed with like
understanding your emotional state that
actually you've kind of Taken focus of
actual forward momentum and living
um and yeah so and I think huge yeah it
is and I think a lot of people who are
in that place they they you know a lot
of people who you have you noticed this
when someone's
just for the first time discovering like
[ __ ] that they've done wrong or the
things that they like not happy about
within themselves they're just
constantly talking about it and they
want to talk about it to everyone and
every you know and and they're going
into such detail and you're just like
but that's someone who
is at the start they just got there they
just started that's always the way
um
and yeah eventually I wanted to get to a
place where I just didn't have to talk
about it yeah you know and I could just
talk about other [ __ ]
yeah or at least look back on it with a
sense of power and not be standing in it
as much yeah because I did all that I've
gone through all of those phases this is
not coming from a judgmental place this
is saying to like this is saying like
you have to kind of like become that
like evangelizing kind of just to just
to you know you've got to destabilize
first I think
that's why it's so hard sometimes to
imagine looking inwards because
initially you're going to have to go
through a period of completely
stabilization
and that's why a lot of people never do
it um which I think it's amazing that
you have uh because and and being public
about it and talks about on your podcast
and a lot of people have probably done
it through you I'm with you yeah I think
I'll you know we just try and we will we
wonder sometimes what is our instrument
why does God have us here that you know
to share whatever you know it's like you
don't even know it's like what is the
little piece of the universe that's
supposed to fly out of you yeah so do
you do you out of side of um
like podcasting is there like a hobby
that you have like a do you play
anything I just got a piano at home oh
really yeah so I'm excited about it did
you talk to me about that one point yeah
I used to play and then I just got a new
piano at home nice it's a you it's a new
used piano so nice yeah it's a baby
grand I think a Baldwin
nice I've got a baby grand I grew up
around amazing this place called Baldwin
Motors I used to do Tire Care I think
yeah you looked it up Baldwin Motors
Covington Louisiana so I don't know if
they make I don't know if they also do
pianos or this is a family I don't know
it could be
joint family but
um I mean it'd be amazing through the
cars and pianos yeah well I think they
did some good cars that's Baldwin Motors
right there
I suspect it's not the same but I oh
they really upgraded they used to just
do mostly tires although Yamaha make
pianos and they also make four thousand
dollars yeah they make a lot of things
yeah what about um
I'm trying to think of something else
what else is in the News Zach anything
else you need out there that man ate
those chickens but I didn't really we
didn't really talk about it well it
didn't do it for me did it was it
something about it it seems grotesque a
little bit I guess is it not
um I don't like those chickens yeah I
don't like those rotisserie chickens it
just have you ever seen 40 chickens
either no it seems like a number of
chickens that shouldn't exist all at the
same time well and it just like would it
you know I just see some man that's
pulling and now the the chicken always
feels like it's just barely chicken it
just it feels like they've been through
it all you know like also if you just
put it down like to you know if we were
really to analyze that situation it's
like
it's not that hard to eat 40 chickens it
every day you know it's like one chicken
every day yeah could you imagine I mean
yeah I could do it you could do that I
could do that I'm a vegetarian like 28
days I would not be I'd be like this oh
I'll be bored yeah but it's like just
watching a man get bored for 40 days
isn't that yeah you can do that anywhere
I could really get bored anyway
someone could I could watch a man
getting bored
I could just talk to the person I might
uh Dom my my producer co-producer friend
asking what it's like to work with me I
I don't think being bored for 40 days is
is entertainment yeah as much as those
people thought it was unless it is now
like that's what Entertainment also is
becoming it's interesting how it's
getting strange like I would watch a
woman like a small woman eat
like maybe a hot dog or a piece of cake
or something online I would watch it to
me that would be very entertaining I'm
now imagining watching you watch her
that's why I laughed well there's a
Japanese show where they have little
children go run to the market for their
mom or something yeah and it's just like
voice it's like a little bit of voice
over and you just watch them go on the
little journey it's the show has to be
for two to four year olds it is
captivating but all of those shows are I
feel like they're Universal ages really
well this one is just something to learn
from things like What's that show can
you look it up brother Japanese children
go to market
[Music]
um it's captive in this show you this
why you're like oh is he gonna you know
is kimchi gonna make the lemonade or
whatever you know and he does it and
you're just damn blown away it's called
old enough old enough yes God it's good
man she's Korean isn't it yeah kimchi is
Korean too but is that is that yeah they
probably changed it there she is right
there
Wow since children as young as two out
into the world alone it's an absolute
roller coaster a Japanese TV show that
abandons toddlers on public transport
it's a one way to look at it man
but it's pretty great you see them go
out there and they're just who is that
right there
does it say doesn't doesn't give a name
oh yeah that's beautiful just says Force
defend for themselves that's one way to
look at it look
it's tough times everywhere
um I think there's something pandemicy
about that isn't there something oh no
it came out before the well done when
did this come out
this is this is a YouTube video Japanese
kids go shopping alone
did you um dude do you remember that
time when I kind of saw you and saw you
do music and make music with Andre 3000
dude I remember you inviting me out to
this place and I it was in Malibu was it
like this cool like kind of little
Shangri-La yeah
it was like a studio because it's like a
rehab yeah it looked like a little rehab
so I pulled up and you and um and I
didn't know that it was him there you
didn't tell me who that you were
wrecking me you know you just said you
were working in a studio yeah yeah and I
came up and you guys were working on
something that's pretty cool wow that
was such an amazing time in my life um
we made a lot of music together did you
guys yeah yeah we did is it interesting
with celebrity how you kind of Pat like
you'll become like you know together for
a while with certain and then yeah it
just you just yeah you just sort of pass
each other but also you know we stayed
in touch like I've talked to him fairly
regularly and
[Music]
um
he's just I mean he's he's like
the the goat yeah as they say so you
know I'll always be honored
just uh I find him always inspiring
probably still
he's still such a different thinker
um about everything and although he did
go on the
um the Rick Rubin podcast and say he's
never gonna release any of the music so
that you guys made
well I mean
he's just generally talking about music
you know full stop so
keep it
I I don't know just he just felt like I
think he was saying something along the
lines of you know he just feels
sort of out the game or like not really
part of that and he's just expressing
himself in all these different ways and
we actually did put something out we did
make yeah we did a thing where he was
playing clarinet and I was playing piano
um I don't I think for me it's like I
don't uh I just want to help as a
producer like because I was in a
producer role
I just want to help someone Express the
thing they want to express and if Andre
3000 isn't in a time of his life where
he wants to make rap music then I'll
help him Express clarinet music
yeah help him Express maybe even just
realizing hey this isn't a time where
you want to put something out yeah which
may change or may not who knows there's
a lot of music get put out
no a lot of music doesn't get put out
what a vast majority of Music doesn't
get bit out are there some amazing songs
out there that you think have been made
that or have we're not have not been put
out there's a lot of mate a lot of songs
out there that I shouldn't think
shouldn't have been put out
um
there's a lot of amazing songs I've
heard in studios that never came out for
sure yet like hundreds
hundreds and they're honestly feels like
a crime honestly it feels like a crime
it's it's terrible
when you hear them and you're like oh I
can't wait I can't wait for that to come
out and people to hear it and
yeah because it's something happens like
promo doesn't work out like someone
somebody like an anr says I'm not really
sure about that one or someone says to
the artist like what a friend of theirs
says oh I don't like that one and it
just turns them off it
or they develop negative association
with that song it's happened with me
plenty of times I mean I've got songs
and
my hard drive is Thousands thousands of
songs that haven't made the cut or
they missed their moment
you know some songs just feel like a
moment and it's like if you don't put
them out soon yeah you're not you just
you're not gonna uh you're never gonna
feel like that again
or maybe sometimes like I didn't nail
the vocal take I didn't fully um so I
don't like the way I'm singing so and I
can't be bothered going back in and
singing it again so there's all these
songs that the the actual DNA of the
song is good
but
you can't be bothered doing it again
going back into that place
yeah and you can't get back there it's
kind of the value of a moment it's like
sometimes you know it's like yeah man we
were so close right there for that
moment yeah and it's like sometimes
those things are batches of songs so
like there'll be a batch of songs that
sounded like
retrograde or there'll be a batch of
songs that sounded like say what you
will but say what you will was the best
of that batch and retrograde was the
best of that batch so I put that out
instead of lots of kind of cop kind of
similar tone songs in a similar tone
that like one is good
did you ever get to work with like
Willie Nelson or John Mayer
um
I've never worked with either of those
no I never have
um but you know Never Say Never I mean
it's really not Willie Nelson is Willie
Nelson is still alive yeah still no is
he making me is he making music and yeah
I think he is he has a daughter I think
our granddaughter Ray Lynn Nelson I
think who also does music all right
um
yeah is there an artist that you feel
like I guess you did you get pitched
artists how does that work do you pitch
does your agent kind of pitch you to
artists how does that kind of work that
usually doesn't work out I've found if
it's a if there's an a r connection or
some kind of industry connection it
doesn't really
you know
it's usually from me just getting in
touch on Instagram and saying like I
love your music or something like that
kind of like how how we met I mean
obviously we're not collaborating
although this you could call it a
collaboration that's true
um but you know we just
like jam Jam's quite good at just
reaching out I sort of learned that from
her she was like you know you can just
reach out to people directly and I was
like she's ready connecting with people
yeah Simon Rex and he's great at
connecting yes yes so that's like two
great connectors is your he's so good in
that movie uh the one red rocket yeah
he's so good in that so ridiculous how
they can make it
yeah at the beginning you're like oh
this is my buddy Simon by the end you're
like oh this is this guy yeah he was
brilliant he was so brilliant and he's
been staying busy since then it's such a
while what an amazing comeback I know
fantastic to watch like I was so [ __ ]
happy to see that yeah Hollywood's so
interesting like that you know
um I mean maybe come back something
maybe the right word sort of just like a
re-entry into the right of the world he
feels like that he'd moved out to the
National Park he was living in a
national park and so that's really even
a bear yeah you're at the end of the
line then because you're basically about
I mean when you're living in a national
park you really you're trying to you
know yeah you're thinking probably about
suicide you're not gonna do it but
there's enough hikes around to keep you
safe
um I'm just joking Simon knows that uh
but he moved out to like Joshua tree and
he was just kind of in his life and then
this producer saw him on Instagram and
said you are perfect yeah because he's
like an incredible looking hilarious
person yeah and good any and he's long
and good you know has some goofy
elements and like
um
but just the biggest heart and so it was
really awesome to get to see him like
and just to see his pride that he felt
like
you wanna everybody wants to feel like
they
are capable maybe or they matter yeah or
that they
we all just want to feel a little bit of
that well like we can just do the thing
that we're good at
in the Limelight for just a moment yeah
and just be like I did that and you know
there's definitely a thing inside a lot
for people that's just sort of screaming
for that occasionally every so often and
if you can if you mat if you happen to
be in a position where you can like
satisfy that voice
it's a nice place to be because
otherwise that can eat you up on it like
if you just can't ever vocalize it or
you can't ever you can't get it
satisfied yeah and it can be satisfied
even just in a relationship it could be
satisfied by that one person that you're
with they could be satisfied by a parent
or a child it could be satisfied by
a million people you know it could it
could need to be it's interesting it
just has to land in that place that it
said that you feel
seen you know yeah totally yes I I uh
and some people it only takes one person
you know it takes a while for a
girlfriend or boyfriend or a parent just
that's all it takes in there yeah
well to be the biggest thing in
someone's life yeah be the center of
somebody's kind of Universe
um
are you um
with anyone at the moment nope I started
doing I I I've been doing a little bit
of just meantime yeah I took 30 days off
of dating so I could get an idea of what
I was kind of doing nice because you can
get so sporadic yeah you know you're
just here and there you go on a date
like do I even care about this what's
going on how's that in Los Angeles is
that difficult it's been a little rocky
Nashville's been even tougher kind of
really really yeah because I don't go
out that much and so it's been kind of a
tough place to go um you know to meet
folks do your interests line up with the
people in LA or in Nashville more I
think they're kind of the same I think
it sort of depends I think you can kind
of find the same type of people anywhere
you know I'm not like
I'm just kind of middle of the road you
know I think I'm trying to think of
something that really turns me off about
somebody
doing this in a restaurant
oh yeah they're done done probably
you're out but if they're attractive
enough you might
I'd probably still order dessert with
them you know so I'd Mill around a bit
so if they did that through start a main
course and dessert and they're just good
like that unless they were like setting
a contaminer for some dope assets that I
didn't know was coming you know or it
was like a flash mob or something that
never started they're just like hey guys
they think it's gonna happen as long as
they just keep
so um have you gotten invited to go play
it like some weird private events or
something that was really interesting
you're like okay this seems strange or
not strange I've done some cool I've
done a couple corporate things that I
ended up not doing anymore after that
because I just felt
in like a couple of fashion events and
things where
very Zoolander type stuff yeah you know
um
but
no I don't I you know I haven't had the
like
I haven't had the
sort of um surreal experience yeah yeah
I haven't really had that in music like
some crazy thing where they invite you
like a baked bean conference or
something everybody's losing their mind
or something no yeah
um
but and if and the things I have done
that were a bit weird I think I'm under
contract to not
talk about
the thing when I say a bit weird I mean
like yeah like
um
like maybe
maybe it's not the kind of gig that like
it was a [ __ ] gig oh yeah it's like a
really [ __ ] gig yeah and there's and I
was like okay let's not have any videos
[Laughter]
well thanks for all your contributions
man I'm glad that um
we get to spend some time together you
know yeah I mean and I'd love to you
know this is I've never done this sort
of I've never been part of the
podcasting Universe particularly yeah at
all it's great we got to that I'm really
glad you that you that you came on and
it felt like like walking through the
screen in a way walking into this uh
interesting it was like just jumping
through YouTube because I've watched
your podcast so many times yeah uh do a
lot of people say that what that you've
watched it no that you well they've just
they've been of you know they've watched
your [ __ ] for so long and they're just
like in the seat where other people are
sitting oh yeah I think it's kind of
fascinating to people I think people
don't know what to think sometimes I
think they're a little bit shocked at
just how the production works and then
suddenly you're there it is interesting
how it goes from just us sitting here
talking into like a conversation that
people could listen to or segments of a
conversation yeah you know I mean we
probably like I feel like our
conversations uh pretty wide reaching
anyway
yeah I think so this reminding me I
think a lot of like why I always have
enjoyed chatting with you you know yeah
me taking time yeah
um what would you say like you think to
like yeah I know this is kind of a
general thing but it's like
if there's somebody who's having trouble
expressing themselves or figuring out
how to do that
um what suggestion do you think you
would give to somebody like that
well
um
I'd say try a few different things
um and if you express yourself to
someone and they kind of like
lightly punish you for doing it uh
whether that's
rejecting you or whatever it is then
maybe they're just not the right person
to do that with but there will be
someone
who will
like your music take you yeah either
yeah like your music or they'll all like
they'll take you as you are basically as
a person
um yeah it's so much we spend so much of
our time trying to adjust our song to
fit the audience yeah instead of finding
the person that hears it you know yeah
and to be I think true confidence is is
just being confident that sorry
using it twice but true confidence is is
being in a situation and just knowing
that
you'd be okay if that person didn't like
what you said or didn't like you know
kind of rejected you or whatever and I
that's hard to get to even even now I
find that pretty difficult
um but uh and in so many ways I've I've
edited myself to death like to to be
okay for everyone else's consumption but
I think
to some extent it's like
kind of
saying what's in on your mind anyway
and come or May because ultimately
the fastest way to find out if you're in
the right situation is to be yourself
and uh you can spend many years
doing the opposite not being yourself
and hoping that people will accept you
uh and ultimately you're just Treading
Water you're never gonna you're never
gonna fully swim you'll you'll only
you'll never scratch the full itch of
of
you you and and
friendship and love and
um real connection because you've never
been your true self and being willing to
let things go by
yeah relationships friends like all
sorts of things like things that may not
yeah being willing to say this isn't it
right now this isn't yeah you know I've
struggled with that with dating and
stuff to be like
I'm just afraid to let go because what
it you know it's just such a reaction
you know what if some part of me there's
a subconscious part of me that's what if
there's nothing else you know yeah is
there like have you met people where
you've you've kind of felt like now the
idea of them not being there is too
scary to actually leave the situation
even though it's probably not right oh I
think it's happening before in the past
for sure you know I think taking some
time from dating and stuff helps me get
a better view of that and see it you
know
um what are the apps I mean I've been in
a relationship for eight years I think
what are the apps now yeah I just got on
I just created a profile on rye but I
haven't opened it I haven't started it
all right so I'm not sure if I want to
I've kind of like it's been like a month
now that I've had it and I just don't
know if I I just don't know how much I
want to be spending my time
trying to manage that and then how much
do I want to just kind of let it happen
but totally and also when your job I
mean I guess you meet a lot of people in
your job
um yeah you meet a decent amount a lot
of them is men that's that's true
although you could you could change that
I guess you could just start inviting
more people you might find more like
mines
um in in in the in the female space yeah
I might have to get out and get a couple
more games around you know it wouldn't
be a bad idea but the I remember being
on in my in my year I think between two
relationships being single and having a
rye account and
one of the I was like scrolling and one
of the interests someone to put was
coconut oil
and I just closed the app and deleted it
and then there's no one back
that's uh it just seems too surface
um James Blake man thank you so much for
spending time brother yeah my my
pleasure it's so nice to be here and
thanks for having me you know I'm a fan
as well as a friend but I just uh I love
what you do and it's great to actually
see the place yeah we're going inside of
the internet man uh yeah yeah thank you
man thank you for all your wonderful
music and um is there music that people
can like you know it's such a generic
question but yeah is there you're gonna
keep making music
that's the plan okay good I'm gonna keep
making it
um the next thing I think is going to be
more of a more of a dance orientated
slash more electronic type thing
um which I've just um
yeah I'm in the process of finishing but
who knows how long that kind of thing
takes
so but I'm also I'm I've got a club
night that I'm I'm doing at the moment
called CMYK uh in partnership with
Rhonda uh a club named Rhonda
um Rhonda presents CMYK and that's my uh
club night that I've been doing around
the country and so if anyone wants to
come and see me DJ and I'm playing a lot
of my new music there
um then they can come and see that
groovy man we'll put the link in the uh
in the description
um thanks so much man great to see you
yeah man loads of love thank you brother
back at you cheers
[Music]
feel I'm falling like these leaves I
must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life I found I
can feel
it in my bones
[Music]